ALLEN ARCH. ATKINS BATES BELL
PORGES BRADFORD COME A YELLOW
CHIANG DALLY DODD THEY'RE ALSO
GALGIANI GLAZER GONZALEZ GROVE
HERTZBERG HILL WEST SO- TANTO
JACKSON JONES LEYVA MCGUIRE
MITCHELL MONNING MORLOCK
MORALE. NIELSEN PAN PORTANTINO
ROTH RUBIO SKINNER STERN ON
BURKE Y. CASKEY WINNER WILK.
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT
WHAT OUR MEMBERS AND OUR GUESTS
BEYOND THE RAIL AND IN THE
GALLERY TO PLEASE RISE WILL BE
LET IN PRAYER THIS AFTERNOON BY
OUR CHAPLAIN SYSTEM CHAU BORMAN
AFTER WHICH WILL BE LED IN THE
PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE BY SENATOR
MCGUIRE. WHAT DO YOU. LET US
CENTER OURSELVES IN GOD'S
PRESENCE AGAIN. WELL WE CAN
pCELEBRATE ST PATRICK THIS YEAR
WITH OUR USUAL FESTIVITIES WE
PRAY TODAY FOR HIS INTERCESSION
TO HELP US BE PEOPLE OF HOPE AS
WE NAVIGATE THE CHALLENGES OF
THE CORONA VIRUS. MAY WE FIND
CONSOLATION IN THIS TRADITIONAL
IRISH PRAYER TRANSLATED FROM
THE GAELIC. GOD OF ALL MYSTERY
YOURS IS THE CITY'S YOURS AS
THE HARVEST GATHER US ONE DAY
INTO YOUR GRAND JURY. GOD AS
BEST AS THE OCEAN YOURS ARE THE
WAVES YOURS ARE THE FISHES.
YEAH THE REST UP INTO YOUR AND
TWINING NETS. FROM BIRTH TO AGE
AND FROM AGE TO DEATH GRADE
LAST IN YOUR GRACE AND LOVING
ARMS. FROM DEATH TO THE END NAS
AND BUT NEW LIFE IN YOUR
PRESENCE MAY REAR RESIDES
ETERNALLY. ALSO WE ASK YOU
PATRICK TO PRAY FOR US
ESPECIALLY ARE HEALTH CARE
PROFESSIONALS FIRST RESPONDERS
AND ARE LEGISLATIVE LEADERS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA AND THE
WORLD. MAY ALL BE WELL A MAN.
WE FEEL LIKE. TO AND WHICH IS
SAN FROM COOL YEAH WE'RE ALL.
WHAT IT IS TO GET THE- WITH
WITH THE BEST. MEMBERS MOVING
TO PULL PRIVILEGES OF FLOOR.
AREN'T CENTER HERTZBERG FOR
WHAT PURPOSE A FOR PURPOSES OF
CALLING A DEMOCRATIC CAUCUS IN
ROOM. FORTY TWO OH THREE FORTY
TWO OH THREE. DEMOCRATIC CAUCUS
IN ROOM FORTY TWO OH THREE.
SAID SENATOR GROVE LIKE TO
COLOR REPUBLICAN CAUCUS IN ROOM
THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE.
REPUBLICAN CAUCUS IN.
THIRTY
ONE NINETY ONE. MEMBERS WE'RE
BACK IN SESSION. THE PRIVILEGES
OF THE FLOOR THERE ARE NINE.
MEMBERS WITHOUT OBJECTION WILL
MOVE TO CONSIDERATION OF DAILY
FILE WE HAVE GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTMENTS ITEM THREE. MADAM
PROTIUM ARE YOU PREPARED FOR
THAT ITEM. I AM OF MISTER
PRESIDENT SECTOR RIPLEY THREE
HELLO NO NO NO NEED TO READ I'M
SORRY MADAM. MADAM PRO TEM. I'M
THIRTY ONE OF MY- MISTER
PRESIDENT CAN WE CAN WE GO BACK
TO. UNDER A MOTIONS AND-
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR BEFORE
WE START WITH. I WOULD ASK FOR
THE COURTESY YES. I JACKSON
THANK YOU- SO COLLEAGUES I
WANTED TO OPEN SESSION- A
LITTLE BIT DIFFERENTLY THAN WE
TYPICALLY DO- WITH THE. REMAIN
OF MY OLLEAGUES I WANTED TO
JUST ACKNOWLEDGE SOME THINGS
THESE ARE VERY MUCH
UNPRECEDENTED TIMES AS THE
GOVERNOR'S ACTIONS YESTERDAY IN
THE ACTIONS WE SEEN FROM LOCAL
COMMUNITIES AND THE FEDERAL
ADMINISTRATION MAKE ABSOLUTELY
CLEAR. WE'VE HEARD FROM HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS THAT CALIFORNIA
IS IN A CRITICAL PERIOD FOR
FLATTENING THE TRANSMISSION
CURVE FOR COVERT NINETEEN. THE
CORONA VIRUS IF WE'RE TO
PREVENT OUR HEALTH CARE SYSTEMS
FROM BEING OVERWHELMED. THE
SENATE HAS ALREADY TAKEN STEPS
TO MAKE THE CAPITAL CITY FOR
AND TO HELP THOSE IN THE
CAPITAL COMMUNITY FOLLOW PUBLIC
HEALTH GUIDELINES THEMSELVES.
AND IT SHOULD BE NOTED THAT
WHILE SOME OF US ON THIS FLOOR
ARE SIXTY FIVE OR OLDER THE
GOVERNOR'S ORDER DOES INCLUDE
EXEMPTIONS. WE APPRECIATE YOUR
BEING HERE FOR THE ACTIONS THAT
WE NEED TO TAKE TODAY. AND AS
YOU CAN SEE WE'VE IMPLEMENTED
SOCIAL DISTANCING IN THE SENATE
CHAMBER. AS YOU KNOW THE
CAPITAL WAS CLOSED TO THE
PUBLIC OVER THE WEEKEND THIS
WEEK'S COMMITTEE HEARINGS HAVE
BEEN POSTPONED. AND SECRETARY
CONTRAIRE US OFFICE HAS
CONTACTED STAFF ABOUT OPTIONS
AVAILABLE TO THEM. BEHIND THE
SCENES WE WORK WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL SERVICES
WITH OUR SERGEANTS WITH OUR
SECURITY SCREENING TEAM ON NEW
PROTOCOLS INCLUDING SOCIAL
DISTANCING. NEW EQUIPMENT AND
NEW SCREENING AND CLEANING
PRACTICES. THE SENATE HAS ALSO
BEEN TESTING REMOTE
CAPABILITIES FOR MEETINGS AND
OTHER LEGISLATIVE ACTIVITY AND
WE'RE WORKING TO HAVE THOSE
SYSTEMS AVAILABLE FOR USE AS
SOON AS POSSIBLE. IN A FEW
MOMENTS WE'LL BE TAKING
ADDITIONAL ACTIONS THAT WILL
ACHIEVE THREE THINGS. TO PUT
ADDITIONAL TOOLS AND RESOURCES
WHERE THEY'RE NEEDED MOST TO
HELP PROVIDE FOR BOTH
LIFESAVING CARE AND
PREVENTATIVE ACTIONS. TO HELP
REDUCE THE RISK OF SENATORS
STAFF AND OTHER MEMBERS OF OUR
CAPITAL COMMUNITY EITHER
CONTRACTING THE VIRUS ARE
CARRYING IT TO OTHERS. AND
THIRD TO PROVIDE AN IMMEDIATE
WAY FOR US TO DO OUR PART TO
HELP FLATTEN THE CURVE WITHOUT
JEOPARDIZING OUR OVERALL WORK
IS LEGISLATURE ON BILLS AND THE
BUDGET. AS I SAID WE WILL NOT
COMPROMISE THE DELIVERY OF FAIR
AND OPEN GOVERNMENT IN OUR
DEMOCRACY. BUT IN THIS TIME OF
URGENCY IF THERE ARE BARRIERS
TO NEEDED ACTION WE MUST TAKE
THE NECESSARY CHANGES.
COLLEAGUES THE FACT THAT IT
CAN'T BE BUSINESS AS USUAL AND
IT CAN'T BE NO BUSINESS AT ALL
WE HAVE TO WORK TOGETHER TO
FIND THE RESPONSIBLE BALANCE
BETWEEN THE TWO AND I KNOW THAT
MY COLLEAGUES. WILL BE ABLE TO
DO THAT AS THE SENATE CONTINUES
OUR RESPONSE TO THE EMERGENCY I
HAVE TO SAY HOW PROUD I AM OF
EVERY SINGLE PERSON WHO SERVES
EVERY SINGLE PERSON IN THIS
CHAMBER WHO SERVES THE PEOPLE
OF CALIFORNIA. IN THE CAPITAL
AND IN OUR DISTRICT OFFICES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE I AM
EXTREMELY APPRECIATIVE. I KNOW
THAT MY COLLEAGUE THE
REPUBLICAN LEADER IS EQUALLY
APPRECIATIVE I'VE HEARD OR
EXPRESS IT NUMEROUS TIMES. I
WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE
CONTRIBUTIONS OF THE SECURITY.
OF HR AND PAYROLL AND
HOUSEKEEPING STAFF WHOSE WORK
IN THE BUILDING WILL CONTINUE
TO KEEP THE LEGISLATURE IN THE
CAPITAL FUNCTIONING DURING THIS
CRISIS. I HOPE WE WOULD ALSO
ALL HONOR AND THANK ALL THE
WORKERS BOTH PUBLIC AND PRIVATE.
PUBLIC AND PRIVATE SECTOR
WORKERS WHO CONTINUE TO WORK
AROUND THE CLOCK INCLUDING OUR
NURSES ARE DOCTORS ARE IN T. S.
PERSONNEL OTHER HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS THEIR
CONTRIBUTION TO US IS ACTUALLY
IMMEASURABLE. AND HELPING EASE
THEIR BURDEN WHICH IS WHAT THE
ACTIONS WE WILL TAKE TODAY WILL
HELP DUE TO HELP EASE THEIR
BURDEN IS THE MOST IMPORTANT
THING ANY OF US CAN DO RIGHT
NOW. SO I WANNA SET THIS
CONTEXT AS WE GO INTO THE
ACTIONS THAT WE WILL TAKE AS
THE SENATE AND AS A
LEGISLATURE. I KNOW I'LL HAVE
MORE TO SAY AS WE MOVE THROUGH
SOME OF THE ACTIONS TODAY AND I
KNOW THAT YOU MAY AS WELL. BUT
I WANTED TO OPEN TODAY'S
PROCEEDINGS WITH THIS OVERVIEW
THIS PERSPECTIVE AND- THIS TONE
IN CONTEXT AS WE GET STARTED
AND SO MISTER PRESIDENT THANK
YOU COLLEAGUES THANK YOU FOR
THE COURTESY OF ALLOWING ME TO
MAKE A FEW COMMENTS. THANK YOU
MEN APPROACH HIM. MOVING TO-
WITHOUT OBJECTION IS WE'RE
GONNA BE MOVING TO
CONSIDERATION OF DAILY FILE. WE
HAVE ITEM NUMBER THREE MAN
APPROACH HIM ARE YOU PREPARED
FOR THAT ITEM YES MISTER
PRESIDENT WHEN YOU'RE READY.
FILE ITEM NUMBER THREE IS THE
CONFIRMATION OF A STANLEY GADDY
TO THE CALIFORNIA ARTS COUNCIL
AND LAUREN BAD TO THE
COMMISSION ON THE STATUS OF
WOMEN AND GIRLS. THESE
APPOINTEES WERE APPROVED BY THE
RULES COMMITTEE ON MARCH FOURTH
I WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. WITHOUT ANY FURTHER
OBJECTION MISTER SECTOR PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ON THE SIDE.
ALLEN HI ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS
AYE BATES L. FOR JUST. BRADFORD
HI HI CABALLERO HI JANE. DALLY
DODD HI BUT ALSO HI GALGIANI HI
GLAZER HI GONZALEZ GROVE.
HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE HUESO
AYE OR TADO HI JACKSON JONES NO
LEYVA. HI MCGUIRE HI MITCHELL
HI MONNING HI MORE LOOK MORRELL
NIELSEN. PAN AYE PORTANTINO HI
ROSS HI RUBIO HI SKINNER STERN
AYE UMBERG. WHY CASKEY HI
WIENER AYE WILK. THIS SURGERY
PLEASE CALL OUT TO MEMBERS.
BATES BELL FOR JUST. CHIANG
DALLY GONZALEZ GROVE JACKSON
MORE LOCK. MORALE NIELSEN
SKINNER I'M BURKE HI WILK. ICE
TWENTY FIVE NO ONE THE POINT IS
CONFIRMED NOW MOVING ON TO
ITEMS ONE INTO GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTMENT SENATOR WORKER YOU
PREPARE. YES THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT MEMBERS FILE ITEM
NUMBER ONE IS A CONFIRMATION OF
MARCO MEECH AS DEPUTY SECRETARY
OF HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
AGENCY MISTER MEACHER SERVE
AGENCY IN VARIOUS CAPACITIES
SINCE TWENTY FIFTEEN AND ALSO
CURRENTLY SERVES AS ACTING
DIRECTOR FOR THE OFFICE OF
STATEWIDE HEALTH PLANNING AND
DEVELOPMENT HE WAS APPROVED BY
RULES COMMITTEE ON A UNANIMOUS
VOTE ON THE- TWENTY SIXTH OF
FEBRUARY. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
APPOINTMENT. AARON SEEN ON THE
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN HI ARCHULETA HI ATINS
AYE BATES WELL FOR JUST HI
BRADFORD I CABALLERO HI CHIANG
HI DALY HI TODD HI BUT ALSO. HI
GALGIANI HI GLAZER HI GONZALEZ
GROVE HI HERTZBERG HI HILL HI
WEST OF. HI HER DAUGHTER HI
JACKSON JONES HI LEYVA. MCGUIRE
HI MITCHELL HI MONNING HI MORE
LOOK HIGH MORALE. NIELSEN PAN
HI PORTANTINO HI ROTH HI RUBIO
HI SKINNER STERN HI AMERICA HI
Y. CASKEY HI WINNER HI WILK HI.
SECTOR PLEASE CALLED UP TO
MEMBERS BATES. BELL GONZALEZ
JACKSON LEYVA HIGH MORALE
NIELSEN SKINNER. VICE THIRTY
TWO KNOWS ZERO THE APPOINTMENT
IS CONFIRMED MOVING ON TO ITEM
NUMBER TWO THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO
SO CONFIRMATION OF MARGUERITE
SWEENEY TO THE WORKERS
COMPENSATION APPEALS BOARD MS
SWEENEY HAS SERVED ON THE BOARD
SINCE TWENTY TWELVE PRIOR TO
THAT SHE WAS AN ATTORNEY IN
PRIVATE PRACTICE SHE'S APPROVED
BY THE RULES COMMITTEE ON MARCH
THE FOURTH ON A FIVE OH VOTE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE APPOINTMENT.
HEARING AND SEEING NONE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN HI ARCHULETA HI ATKINS
AYE BATES BELL FOR JUST HI
BRADFORD AYE CAMBIADO HI CHIANG
HI TALLY HI DODD. I THAT ALSO
HI GALGIANI AYE GLAZER HI
GONZALEZ GROVE HI HERTZBERG AYE
HILL HI WES SO. I HER DAUGHTER
HI JACKSON JONES HI LEYVA HI
MCGUIRE HI MITCHELL HI MONNING
HI MORE LOCK. HIGH MORALE
NIELSEN PAN AYE PORTANTINO HI
ROTH HI RUBIO HI SKINNER. STERN
HI UMBERG HIGHWAY CASKEY HI
WIENER AYE WILK HI. ICE THIRTY
TWO NO ZERO APPOINTMENT IS
CONFIRMED NOW MOVING ON TO
ITEMS FOR. THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT FILE ITEM NUMBER
FORCE A CONFIRMATION OF ERICA
COURTNEY AND DR LISA WILKINS TO
THE COMMISSION ON THE STATUS OF
WOMEN AND GIRLS IS KOURTNEY IS
A U. S. ARMY VETERAN AND THE
CEO OF TWENTY TWENTY VET
INCORPORATED AND DOCTOR WILL
CONSIST CURRENTLY THE
COMMISSION'S CHAIR IN THE OWNER
AND FOUNDER OF HERBAL. TO
MACULA THEIR APPROVED BY THE
RULES COMMITTEE ON THE FOURTH
OF MARCH I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION THE BAIT ON THIS
APPOINTMENT. HEARING IN THREE
NINE MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN HI AT
PARTULA HI ATKINS HI BATES BELL
BORDERS HI BRADFORD HI CAMBIADO
HI CHAN I DALY HI TODD. THAT
ALSO HI GALGIANI HI GLAZER HI
GONZALEZ GROVE HI HERTZBERG HI
HILL. HI WEST OF HI HI HER
DAUGHTER HI JACKSON JONES NO
LEYVA. HI REQUIRE HI MITCHELL
HI MONNING HI MORE LOOK.
MORRELL NIELSEN PAN AYE
PORTANTINO HI ROTH HI RUBIO HI
SKINNER. STERN HI UMBERG HI
WHAT CASKEY HI WIENER AYE WILK
HI. SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS BATES. BELL DODD
HI GONZALEZ JACKSON MORE LOCK
MORRELL NIELSEN SKINNER. ICE
THIRTY KNOWS ONE THE
APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED MOVING
ON TO ITEM NUMBER FIVE. THANK
YOU MISTER PRESIDENT FILE ITEM
NUMBER FIVE IS THE CONFIRMATION
OF KIMBERLY JOHNSON AS DIRECTOR
OF THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES PRIOR TO THIS
APPOINTMENT MISS JOHNSON SERVED
AS DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF THE
DEPARTMENT'S FAMILY ENGAGEMENT
AND EMPOWERMENT DIVISION SHE IS
APPROVED BY THE RULES COMMITTEE
ON MARCH ELEVENTH ON UNANIMOUS
FIVE OH VOTE. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM HEARING AND SEEING
NONE MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN I
ARCHULETA. AYE ATKINS AYE BATES
BELL BORDERS HI BRADFORD HI
CAMBIADO I CHIANG HI DALY AYE
DODD. HI THERE ALSO HI GALGIANI
HI GLAZER HI GONZALEZ GROVE HI
HERTZBERG HI HILL I WAS SO. HI
HER DAUGHTER HI JACKSON. JONES
HI LEYVA HI MCGUIRE HI MITCHELL
HI MONNING HI MORE LOCK HIGH
MORALE. NIELSEN PAN AYE
PORTANTINO AYE ROTH HI RUBIO HI
SKINNER STERN HI NUMBER FIVE
CASKEY HI WIENER AYE WILK. HI.
ICE THIRTY TWO NO ZERO THE
APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED MOVING
ON TO FILE ITEM SIX THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT FILE ITEM
NUMBER SIX IS A CONFIRMATION OF
JEFFREY MACABRE AS
UNDERSECRETARY OF
ADMINISTRATION AT CDC ARE
MISTER COMER HAS SPENT HIS
ENTIRE TWENTY SEVEN YEAR CAREER
AT CDC ARE SERVING IN NUMEROUS
ROLES AT THE DEPARTMENT HE WAS
APPROVED ON UNANIMOUS FIVE A
VOTE BY THE RULES COMMITTEE ON
MARCH ELEVENTH I RESPECTFULLY
ASK. FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THE APPOINTMENT. HEARING AND
SEEING NONE MISS SECTOR PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN HI
ARCHULETA HI ATKINS AYE BATES
BELL BORDERS HI BRADFORD AYE
CABALLERO AYE CHAIN AYE DALY
AYE DODD I DID ALSO HI GALGIANI
AYE GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ. GROVE
I HERTZBERG AYE HILL I WAS SO.
HI YOUR TOTAL HI JACKSON JONES
HI LEYVA. HI MCGUIRE HI
MITCHELL AYE MONNING HI MORE
LOCK HI MORRELL NIELSEN PAN HI
PORTANTINO HI ROTH HI RUBIO HI
SKINNER. STERN HI UMBERG HI Y.
CASKEY HI WIENER AYE WILK HI.
ICE THIRTY TWO NO ZERO THE
APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED OUR
FINAL MY VITAL FINAL ITEM
NUMBER SEVEN THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT FILE ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN IS A CONFIRMATION OF
CAN'T POKE AS DIRECTOR OF THE
OFFICE OF ADMINISTRATIVE LAW
PRIOR TO THIS APPOINTMENT
MISTER POLK SERVICE
UNDERSECRETARY OF CDC ARE HE
WAS APPROVED ON A UNANIMOUS
FIVE A VOTE BY THE RULES
COMMITTEE ON THE ELEVENTH OF
MARCH I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE BOTH. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THIS
APPOINTMENT HEARING AND SEEING.
MISTER SECTOR PLEASED THE ROLL.
ALLEN HI ARCHULETA HI ATKINS
AYE BATES L. BORDERS HI
BRADFORD HI CAMBIADO HI CHIANG
HI DALY AYE DODD HI THERE ALSO
HI GALGIANI HI GLAZER. HI
GONZALEZ GROVE HI HERTZBERG AYE
HILL AYE HUESO HI TARA HI
JACKSON JONES HI LEYVA. HI
MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL AYE
MONNING AYE MORLOCK HIGH MORALE
NIELSEN PAN AYE PORTANTINO HI
ROTH HI RUBIO HI SKINNER. STERN
HI WHY BECAUSE HE HI NUMBER HI
WIENER. HI WILK. HI. I SIX
THIRTY TWO NO ZERO THE
APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED. NOW
MOVING TO MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE RATE. OFFICE OF THE
GOVERNOR MARCH SIXTEENTH TWENTY
TWENTY TO THE MEMBERS OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE AND THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSEMBLY. OUR
STATE OUR NATION AND OUR WORLD
ARE FACING A CHALLENGE
UNPRECEDENTED IN MODERN TIMES.
THE COVERT NINETEEN PANDEMIC
COMPELS US ALL TO FIND NEW WAYS
OF COMING TOGETHER EVEN AS WE
MUST ALSO SEEK OUT NEW WAYS OF
STAYING APART. RECOGNIZING THE
MAGNITUDE OF THIS MOMENT ON
MARCH FOR TWENTY TWENTY I
PROCLAIMED A STATE OF EMERGENCY
IN CALIFORNIA. IN DOING SO I
FOUND THAT THE CONDITIONS SET
FORTH IN GOVERNMENT CODE
SECTION EIGHT FIVE FIVE EIGHT
THE HAD BEEN MET. MOREOVER I
HEREBY FIND THAT THE DECLARED
STATE OF EMERGENCY CONSTITUTES
A STATE OF EMERGENCY WITHIN THE
MEANING OF ARTICLE THIRTEEN B.
SECTION THREE SUBDIVISION SEE
PARAGRAPH TWO OF THE CALIFORNIA
CONSTITUTION. THE CALIFORNIA
CONSTITUTION GENERALLY PROVIDES
IN ARTICLE FOUR SECTION EIGHT
SUBDIVISION BE PARAGRAPH TO.
THAT NOBILL MAYBE PASSED OR
ULTIMATELY BECOME A STATUTE
UNTIL IT HAS BEEN PRINTED
DISTRIBUTED TO THE MEMBERS AND
PUBLISHED ON THE INTERNET IN
ITS FINAL FORM FOR AT LEAST
SEVENTY TWO HOURS BEFORE THE
VOTE. THE CONSTITUTION FOR THE
PROVIDES HOWEVER THAT THIS
SEVENTY TWO HOUR NOTICE PERIOD
MAY BE WAIVED IF THE GOVERNOR
SUBMITS TO THE LEGISLATURE A
WRITTEN STATEMENT THAT THIS-
THE DISPENSING WITH THIS NOTICE
PERIOD FOR THAT BILL IS
NECESSARY TO ADDRESS THE STATE
OF EMERGENCY. THAT HAS BEEN
DCLARED BY THE GOVERNOR.
WITHIN THE MEANING OF ARTICLE
THIRTEEN B. SECTION THREE
SUBDIVISION SEE PARAGRAPH TO.
TODAY I WRITE TO YOU TO TATE
THE OBVIOUS WE MUST RISE TO THE
CHALLENGE FACING OUR STATE WITH
EVERY TOOL AT OUR DISPOSAL AND
WITHOUT A SECOND OF DELAY. WE
CANNOT HESITATE TO MEET THIS
MOMENT. ACCORDINGLY I SUBMIT TO
YOU THIS WRITTEN STATEMENT THAT
TO ADDRESS THE STATE OF
EMERGENCY I HAVE DECLARED IT IS
NECESSARY TO DISPENSE WITH THE
SEVENTY TWO HOUR NOTICE PERIOD
SET FORTH IN ARTICLE FOUR
SECTION EIGHT SUBDIVISION BE
PARAGRAPH TWO OF THE CALIFORNIA
CONSTITUTION. AS TO THE
FOLLOWING LEGISLATION. AB
EIGHTY NINE AB ONE SEVENTEEN SB
EIGHTY NINE SB ONE SEVENTEEN.
IN ADDITION TO ADDRESSING THE
STATE EMERGENCY I PROCLAIMS IN
CONNECTION WITH COVERT NINETEEN
ON MARCH FOR TWENTY TWENTY.
THIS LEGISLATION ALSO ADDRESSES
THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN CAMPFIRE
FOR WHICH A STATE OF EMERGENCY
WAS PROCLAIMED ON NOVEMBER
EIGHT TWENTY EIGHTEEN. I LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU IN
THE WEEKS DAYS AND HOURS AHEAD
AS WE CONDUCT TO THE URGENT
BUSINESS OF OUR STATE.
SINCERELY GAVIN NEWSOM GOVERNOR.
MEMBERS PURSUANT TO ARTICLE
FOUR. SECTION EIGHT B. TWO
THERE IS A LETTER A TO TEST
FROM THE GOVERNOR DISPENSING
WITH THE NOTICE PERIOD TO THE
STATE OF EMERGENCY THIS
PROVISION REQUIRES A CONCURRENT
TO TWO THIRDS. OF THE
MEMBERSHIP. SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. IS THERE
OBJECTION TO A UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. HEARING SEEN NONE. HI
THIRTY TWO NO ZERO. THE
CONSTITUTION IS WHAT. MESSAGES
FROM THE ASSEMBLY WILL BE
DEEMED READ REPORTS OF
COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED. NOW
MOVING TO MOTIONS RESOLUTIONS
AND NOTICES. MADAM PRO TEM
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MISTER
SPEAKER. THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT. FIVE I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO TAKE UP
SENATE RESOLUTION EIGHTY SIX
WITHOUT REFERENCE TO COMMITTEE
OR FILE. WITHOUT OBJECTION
SECTOR PLEASE READ. THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT CALLING FOR
THE PLEASE READ OF SORRY.
SENATE RESOLUTION EIGHTY SIX BY
SENATOR ATKINS RELATIVE TO THE
STANDING RULES OF THE SENATE
FOR THE TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY
REGULAR SESSION. MADAM PRO TEM.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES I RISE TO PRESENT S.
R. EIGHTY SIX WHICH MAKES
SEVERAL CHANGES TO OUR SENATE
RULES THESE CHANGES PROVIDE THE
SENATE THE FLEXIBILITY TO
FUNCTION DURING THIS TIME OF
CRISIS WITH THIS RESOLUTION WE
ARE ADOPTING NEW SENATE RULE
EIGHTY SIX THAT ALLOWS FOR
ADMINISTRATIVE. PROCEDURES
DURING EMERGENCY THE FOLLOWING
CHANGES APPLIED DURING A STATE
OR LOCAL EMERGENCY IS DEFINED
BY THE PRESIDENT PRO TEMPORE A-
THE PRESIDENT PRO TEMPORE A MAY
ASSIGN REMOVE OR REPLACE ANY
MEMBER OF A STANDING COMMITTEE.
MAY ESTABLISH AN APPOINT
MEMBERS TO ANY SPECIAL
COMMITTEE THEY DEEM NECESSARY.
MAY AUTHORIZE A STANDING
COMMITTEE OR SPECIAL COMMITTEE
TO CONDUCT A MEETING WITH ONE
OR MORE MEMBERS PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY AS DEFINED. THIS
AUTHORIZES THE PUBLIC TO
PARTICIPATE REMOTELY AS WELL.
AND FINALLY THE PRESIDENT PRO
TEMPORE A MAY AUTHORIZE THE
SENATE TO CONDUCT A MEETING IN
WHICH ONE OR MORE SENATORS
PARTICIPATE REMOTELY AS DEFINED.
COLLEAGUES THESE CHANGES WILL
ALLOW THE SENATE TO BE MORE
NIMBLE AND RESPONSIVE DURING
EMERGENCIES. IT'S MY VERY
STRONG HOPE THAT THEY WILL ONLY
NEED TO COME INTO PLAY ONLY
RARELY IF EVER I ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE. MR MAJORITY LEADER
FOR WHAT PURPOSE OF I RISE TO
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
ADOPT THIS RESOLUTION BY A
VOICE VOTE. WITHOUT OBJECTION
IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE SIDE OF. HEARING
NONE. ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SAY
AYE. THOSE OPPOSED SAY NAY THE
ICE OUR. OKAY MOVING TO SENATOR
MITCHELL FILE ITEM SIXTY SIX
ARE YOU PREPARED THAT ITEM I AM
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL EIGHTY NINE BY THE
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND FISCAL
REVIEW THE STATE BUT A REAL AN
ACT RELATING TO THE STATE
BUDGET AND MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION THEREFORE TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BUDGET BILL.
SIR MITCHELL FLOOR JURORS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES SOME
SENATE BILL EIGHTY NINE IS BACK
TO OUR FLOOR FOR CONCURRENT IT
IS WHAT WE'RE CALLING BUDGET
BILL JUNIOR. IS ASSOCIATE WITH
THE BUDGET ACT OF TWENTY
NINETEEN THIS BILL MAKES
TECHNICAL AND SUBSTANTIVE
CHANGES TO THE BUDGET ACT TO
ADDRESS THE GOVERNOR'S MARK
FORTY FOUR. TWENTY TWENTY
PROCLAMATION OF EMERGENCY
RELATED TO. CORONA VIRUS AND
CONTINUED RESPONSE EFFORTS
RELATED TO THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN
CAMPFIRE. THE BILL DOES THESE
THREE THINGS COLLEAGUES AT
APPROPRIATE FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS FROM THE
GENERAL FUND. TO BE UTILIZED
FOR ANY PURPOSE RELATED TO THE
MARCH FOURTH TWENTY TWENTY
PROCLAMATION OF EMERGENCY UPON
SEVENTY TWO HOUR WRITTEN NOTICE
TO THE JOINT LEGISLATIVE BUDGET
COMMITTEE. THIS AMOUNT MAY BE
INCREASED IN INCREMENTS OF
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS AND NO
SOONER THAN SEVENTY TWO HOURS
AFTER THE DIRECTOR OF FINANCE
NOTICES THE GOP SEE THE NEED
FOR THE INCREASE. IT STATES THE
INTENT OF THE LEGISLATURE THAT
THE ADMINISTRATION WORK WITH
STAKEHOLDERS INCLUDING MEMBERS
OF THE LEGISLATURE AND LET'S
STAFF AND DEVELOPING STRATEGIES
TO BE CONSIDERED FOR INCLUSION
AND THE BUDGET ACTIVE TWENTY
TWENTY. TO ASSIST INDIVIDUALS
NON PROFITS AND SMALL
BUSINESSES EXPERIENCE ECONOMIC
HARDSHIPS DUE TO THE IMPACTS OF
CALL THE NINETEEN. IT
APPROPRIATE EIGHTY FOUR POINT
ONE MILLION DOLLARS IN GENERAL
FUND TO DEPARTMENT OF RESOURCES
RECYCLING IN RECOVERY THE
COMPLETE TREE REMOVAL
OPERATIONS IN BUTTE COUNTY
RELATED TO THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN
CAMPFIRE. COLLEAGUES I'M- HAPPY
TO BE ABLE TO PRESENT THIS BILL
TODAY ON IT BALLOTS TO ALL OF
YOU THAT THE STATE HAS
SIGNIFICANT CASH BALANCES- CASH
ON HAND AS WELL AS- A HEARTY
RESERVE REALLY AS A RESULT OF
OUR COLLECTIVE. PRUDENT
BUDGETING OVER THE LAST DECADE
WE ARE IN A STRONG POSITION TO
HELP CALIFORNIA MANAGE THE
CURRENT CRISIS I ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE ON CONCURRENT. THANK
YOU SENATOR MITCHELL'S CENTER
DALLAS. THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT MEMBERS I ALSO RISE
IN SUPPORT OF THE THIS IS A-
BUDGET ASK- AS SOMEBODY WHO.
OVER THE LAST EIGHT YEARS HAS.
BEEN INVOLVED IN SOME NATURAL
DISASTERS I HAPPEN TO REPRESENT.
ORVILLE WHEN IT WAS OVERFLOWING
IN THIS BILL WAY HAD BEEN
BROKEN ALSO REPRESENTED THE
BUTTE COUNTYDURING THE
CAMPFIRES AND NOW WE ARE FACED
WITH SOMETHING THAT IS NOT JUST
SPECIFIC TO A DISTRICT BUT IS
STATEWIDE AND- NATIONWIDE AND
WORLDWIDE. AND RIGHT NOW IS THE
TIME WHERE WE NEED TO STEP UP
AND- YOU KNOW GIVE SOME COMFORT
THIS IS. WE DON'T REALLY KNOW
THE IMPACT OF WHAT. THE FUTURE
WILL HOLD. BUT WE DO KNOW THAT-
MAYBE WE CAN FLAT THAT KERR
ABOUT AND- STOP WHAT WE'RE
SEEING HAPPENING IN ITALY AND
IN OTHER COUNTRIES. SO AS YOU
KNOW THIS STATE IS VERY DIVERSE
WHAT HAPPENS IN HAD AYE I SAY
WEEK SELF QUARANTINE A LOT IN
OUR DISTRICT WE HAVE YOU KNOW
IN SOME PLACES. LESS THAN TEN
PEOPLE PER SQUARE MILE. WHICH
IS. GOOD FOR US IN THIS
SITUATION. BUT ALSO THE
CHILDREN IN MY DISTRICT THAT
ARE RELYING ON THEIR SCHOOL
LUNCHES- WHO ARE NOT CLOSE TO
THEIR SCHOOL IN THE TIME THAT
THEIR SCHOOLS ARE OUT ARE
THINGS THAT WE ARE GOING TO
HAVE TO. DEAL WITH OVER THE
NEXT COMING WEEKS AND I KNOW
THAT OUR GOVERNOR IN THE STUFF
I'VE READ HAS ADDRESS THOSE
ISSUES AND SO I JUST WANT TO
SAY TO THE LEGISLATURE IN TO
THE GOVERNOR. I THANK YOU I
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING ON THE
EFFECTS OF WHAT THIS
LEGISLATION WILL DO AND ALSO
WHAT WE DON'T KNOW. THE TRICKLE
DOWN EFFECT TO OUR ECONOMY
WHICH I THINK IS GONNA BE
SOMETHING WE WILL DEFINITELY BE
FACING- IN THE FUTURE AND IS
GOING TO BE A HUGE CHALLENGE AS
SOMEBODY WHO WAS ON A BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND WE SAW THE DOT
COM. RISE AND FALL OF THAT AND
ALSO IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHT WE
SAW THE COMING DOWN OF THE
HOUSING. CRISIS THIS WILL BE
SIMILAR AYE I BELIEVE HOPEFULLY
NOT. BUT THAT'S WHEN- OUR JOB
WILL BE VERY DIFFICULT AND
WE'LL HAVE TO MAKE SOME REALLY
TOUGH DECISIONS SO I JUST WANT
TO SAY. THANK YOU TO THE PRO
TEM WHO HAS BEEN- WORKING WITH
OUR CAUCUS HAS BEEN. EMAILING
TEXTING THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
HAS STEPPED UP. BUT NOW IS THE
TIME FOR US TO DO OUR JOBS WE
ARE I ILL PERSONALLY BE
AVAILABLE I KNOW MANY OTHERS
WILL BE- OVER THE COMING WEEKS.
TO DO THE RIGHT THING FOR
CALIFORNIANS AND TO SET THE
PACE- NOLLIE FOR OUR STATE BUT
FOR THE NATION AND FOR THE
WORLD SO WITH THAT. I WOULD
URGE AN AYE VOTE ON. SB EIGHTY
NINE THANK CENTER DOLLARS
CENTER Y. COFFEE I MISS PRESENT
I RISE IN SUPPORT OF SB- EIGHTY
NINE I'M ONE OF THE- BAY AREA
COUNTIES THAT ARE NOW
SHELTERING INS IN PLACE IN THE
THIS STATE OF EMERGENCY
REQUIRES OUR LEADERSHIP TO SHOW
CALM AND NOT TO PANIC AND HAVE
THE PUBLIC RESPOND AS OUR
COUNTIES ARE NOW ARE BUT BY
ORDER OF THAT HEALTH OFFICER
ARE ORDERING PEOPLE TO STAY AT
HOME AS THEY CAN BUT THERE ARE
CERTAIN ESSENTIAL BUSINESSES
THAT MUST REMAIN OPEN I WANT TO
APPLAUD THE GENTLEMAN. FROM
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA WHOSE AND
FALL WITH THE AGRICULTURAL- IN
THIS INDUSTRY THAT SO ESSENTIAL
TO ALL OF US AT THIS TIME OF
NEED AND I KNOW ONE OF THE
ESSENTIAL BUSINESSES THAT HAVE
BEEN- THAT ARE CALLED UPON BY
THE HEALTH OFFICER OF SANTA
CLARA COUNTY IS DEFINED IN PART
IF I MAY READ HOW OBVIOUSLY
HEALTH CARE OPERATIONS BUT ALSO
GROCERY STORES CERTIFIED
FARMERS MARKETS FARMING-
PRODUCE STANDS SUPERMARKETS
FOOD BANKS CONVENIENCE STORES
AND OTHERS ENGAGED IN THE SALE
OF FRESH FRUITS AND VEGETABLES
FRESH MEATS AND- FISH AND
POULTRY THIS IS THE TIME FOR
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA THAT.
ARE FEEDING US THAT THAT WE
HAVE ACCESS TO THOSE THINGS AND
THOSE ARE THE LIMITED
ESSENTIAL- BUSINESSES THERE
THERE AND WITH THAT I WOULD
TONIGHT VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR
ALSO. THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT I TO RISE TO SUPPORT
AS BE EIGHTY NINE I DO SO AT
THE SAME TIME THAT I URGE OUR
GOVERNOR TO DO WHAT THIS BODY
HAS DONE OVER AND OVER AND THAT
IS TO STAND WITH ALL
CALIFORNIANS REGARDLESS OF
THEIR IMMIGRATION STATUS AS
THIS THE PURPOSE OF THIS
FUNDING SAYS IT'S TO ASSIST
INDIVIDUALS AND- I JUST. ALL
INDIVIDUALS IN THIS IN THE
STATE THAT NOBODY GETS EXCLUDED
FROM GETTING THE KIND OF HEALTH
CARE AND THE SAFETY NET THEY
DESERVE- AND NOT ONLY THAT IT'S
THE SMARTEST THING TO DO
BECAUSE WE WILL NOT GET THROUGH
THIS CRISIS IF WE DO NOT GIVE
THE TESTING THE TREATMENT AND
THE CARE THAT EVERYONE NEEDS
RIGHT NOW SENIORS WHO OVER
SIXTY FIVE WHO ARE SAID TO BE
THE MOST VULNERABLE GROUP.
RIGHT NOW IF YOU ARE
UNDOCUMENTED OVER SIXTY FIVE
YOU DO NOT HAVE ACCESS TO
HEALTH CARE SO TO MY COLLEAGUES
TO OUR UP UP PUT TâM WHO HAS
BEEN ON THE FOREFRONT OF THIS
ISSUE- I ASKED THE GOVERNOR TO
PLEASE INCLUDE THIS IN HIS
DELIBERATIONS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SENATOR GROWTH. THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT I TO RISE IN
SUPPORT OF- SB EIGHT NINE NINE
AND ALSO- SKEWS ME AS BE EIGHTY
NINE I APOLOGIZE BUT ALSO WOULD
LIKE TO ENCOURAGE THE GOVERNOR
TO THINK ABOUT THE THINGS THAT
ARE NOT COVERED IN THIS I
REALIZE THAT THE MONEY'S GOING
TO BE APPROPRIATED TO HELP THE
HOMELESS THAT IS SOMETHING THAT
WE MAKE SURE WE DO TO MAKE SURE
THAT ENCAMPMENTS- AND HIGH
DENSITY AS SHELTERS DO NOT AND
HAVE THE SAME SITUATION OF AN
OUTBREAK THAT WE'VE SEEN IN
OTHER COUNTRIES. AND I WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT- THE SAME GOALS
THAT HE HAS IN SOME OF THE
SPENDING MANY IS EXACTLY WHAT
MYSELF AND MY COLLEAGUES
SUPPORT BUT THINGS THAT WERE
NOT ADDRESSED- I REALIZE THAT
THERE'S GOING TO BE MANY THERE
FOR EMPLOYEES TO BE ABLE TO
TAKE TIME OFF WORK AND THE
HOMELESS POPULATION WHICH I
JUST MENTIONED BUT IF WE DON'T
GO BACK AND HELP THE BUSINESS
COMMUNITY HAS LOST A TREMENDOUS
AMOUNT OF REVENUE. AND BEING
ABLE TO KEEP THOSE EMPLOYEES
EMPLOYED THEN WILL CONTINUALLY
BE I'M GOING BACK TO ADDRESS
THE ISSUES OF EMPLOYEES NOT
GETTING A PAYCHECK AND
EMPLOYEES POSSIBLY NOT HAVING A
JOB TO GO BACK TO THE EMPLOYER
ISN'T TAKING CARE OF AND THEN
IMPACTS ARE MINIMIZED ON THEM A
LOT OF PEOPLE IN OUR DISTRICTS
ARE EXPERIENCING ESPECIALLY THE
BUSINESS OWNER SMALL BUSINESS
OWNERS RESTAURANTS- BARS AT.
EVEN THE MCDONALDS CORPORATIONS
THIS THE BUSINESS OWNERS ARE
TEXTING ME I'VE GOTTEN TAX FROM
OUR HOSPITAL EXECUTIVES THAT
ARE CONCERNED ABOUT A STAFFING
RATIOS AND I KNOW THAT'S A BIG
A POLITICAL ISSUE BUT WE NEED
TO SET POLITICS ASIDE AND WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT IF WE
HAVE A NURSE ON STAFF IS
CAPABLE OF TAKING CARE OF THREE
TO FIVE TO TEN PATIENTS THAN
THAT NEEDS TO BE LIFTED I MEAN
THERE ARE SOME THINGS THAT
DESPERATELY NEED BE ADDRESS SO
THAT WE LIMóN EIGHT THE RED
TAPE. SO THAT WE CAN SERVICE
OUR CONSTITUENTS THAT ARE ALL
STRUGGLING WITH THIS ISSUE AND
THAT WE CAN ADDRESS THE
EMERGENCY CRISIS AT OUR STATE
FINDS US I AND SO AGAIN I WOULD
ASK THE GOVERNOR TO THINK ABOUT
THE EMPLOYMENT ASPECT OF IT
BECAUSE WITHOUT THE EMPLOYER
AND THE EMPLOYEE HAVE A JOB TO
GO BACK TO AND- THAT COULD
CREATE A HUGE PROBLEM AND ALSO
IT CAN ALSO IMPACT A MORE
HOMELESS. THE OTHER- ISSUE THAT
I WANTED TO TALK ABOUT WAS THE
FARMING COMMUNITY AND I
APPRECIATE MY I'M CALLING FROM
THE BAY AREA. I'VE BEEN. A HAD
PICTURES SENT TO ME ABOUT
GROCERY STORES EMPTY SHELVES
EVERYWHERE. AND WE HAVE- THE
GOVERNOR OF THIS STATE IS
BLESSED. TO BE ABLE TO GOVERNOR
STATE. IT HAS THE TOP THREE
FOOD PRODUCING COUNTIES IN THE
WORLD. MY COLLEAGUE- FROM THE
CENTRAL VALLEY. BOTH MY
COLLEAGUES ALL THREE OF YOU
GUYS I GUESS FROM THE CENTRAL
VALLEY THAT JOIN ME- FRESNO
KERN AND TULARE OR THE TOP FOOD
PRODUCING COUNTIES FOR THE
ENTIRE. WORLD AND 99% OF SOME
PRODUCTS ARE GROWN RIGHT HERE.
IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY THAT FEED
THE WORLD IN FEEDER
CONSTITUENTS. SO I THINK WE
NEED TO LEARN A LESSON IN ON
THIS ON THIS ISSUE THAT WE'RE
DEALING WITH. THAT WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT FOOD IS PRODUCED
HERE DOMESTICALLY SO THAT WE
CAN CONTINUE TO NOT BE-
DEPENDING ON OTHER FOREIGN
NATIONS TO GET FOOD PRODUCTS
AND WE DO DESPERATELY NEED
THEM. AM I HOPE THE GOVERNOR
TAKES SAID IN THIS
CONSIDERATION. I DO APPLAUD HIM
AND EVERYBODY THIS WORKED HARD
THE SENATE PROTEIN HAS BEEN
AMAZING. ON COMMUNICATION AND
SO IS THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
WITH US. IN THE REPUBLICAN
CAUCUS WE APPRECIATE THAT VERY
MUCH. AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO-
WORKING THROUGH THIS ISSUE IN
THIS EMERGENCY RESPONSE THAT WE
HAVE. TOGETHER AS A TEAM. AND
NOT A SEPARATE PARTIES. THANK
YOU SENATOR PAT. THANK YOU A
MISS PRESIDENTE CENTERS I TO
RISE IN SUPPORT OF THIS VERY
IMPORTANT- ACTION THAT WE ARE
ABOUT TO TAKE HER AS A
PHYSICIAN I KNOW THAT THE CODE
NINETEEN IS A VIRUS THAT.
THREATENS ALL OF US HERE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
APPRECIATE-THE- EXPRESSIONS OF
UNITY HERE BECAUSE WE ALL DO
YOU NEED TO COME TOGETHER. AND
WORK TOGETHER TO BE SURE WE
MITIGATE THE IMPACT OF THIS-
INSPECTION- IT IS A COMMENT ON
EACH OF US NOT JUST HERE IN
THIS CHAMBER BUT IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA TO DO WHAT WE CAN
TO LIMIT AND SLOW THE SPREAD OF
THIS DISEASE AND CERTAINLY I
THINK THIS PARTICULAR BILL
EXPRESSES OUR TRUST AND FAITH
IN OUR GOVERNOR GOVERNOR AND
OUR LEADERSHIP TO USE. THE
RESOURCES OR STATE WISELY IN A
WAY THAT WILL AGAIN PROTECT THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA AND
CERTAINLY HERE WE ARE TOGETHER
JOIN TOGETHER IN PARTNERSHIP
WITH OUR COLLEAGUES IN THE
ASSEMBLY AND WHAT THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE IN SAYING
THAT WE ARE STANDING TOGETHER
IS CALIFORNIANS TO PROTECT ALL
CALIFORNIANS AND SO CERTAINLY I
WANTED- URGE I HOPEFULLY
UNANIMOUS SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL
SO THAT WE CAN HAVE THE
CAPACITY TO BE ABLE TO TAKE ON
THIS CRISIS AND TO ENSURE THAT
WE STOP. AND START THE SLOW THE
SPREAD THIS DISEASE AND PROTECT
AS MANY CALIFORNIANS AS
POSSIBLE ORIGINAL VOTE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU CENTER WINNER.
BUT THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
I RISE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS- EMERGENCY APPROPRIATION-
TO ALLOW- THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TO FIGHT OCTOBER
NINETEEN- TO SAVE LIVES AND TO
MAKE SURE THAT OUR HEALTH CARE
SYSTEM HAS THE CAPACITY TO KEEP
PEOPLE HEALTHY- I ALSO JUST
WANT TO NOTE THAT THIS
APPROPRIATION IN MY VIEW NEEDS
TO BE A DOWN PAYMENT- AND DIED
AS A DOWN PAYMENT IN CALIFORNIA
AND I HOPE ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
TO REBUILDING OUR PUBLIC HEALTH
SYSTEM- TO MAKING SURE THAT NOT
SAYS FOR NOW WE HAVE TO GET
THROUGH THIS CRISIS BUT IN THE
FUTURE THAT WE THAT THIS NEVER
HAPPENS AGAIN- THAT WE HAVE A
HEALTH SYSTEM IN THIS COUNTRY
WHERE WE HAVE THE CAPACITY TO
THE TAX AND THE CATS IN THE
TAKE FIRM ACTION TO PROTECT OUR
PUBLIC EARLY AND BEFORE IT GETS
TO THIS POINT- AND TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE HAVE ENOUGH HOSPITAL
BEDS AND VENTILATORS IN ALL OF
THE OTHER NEEDS- TO KEEP PEOPLE
HEALTHY. THIS IS A DOWN
PAYMENT- WE NEED TO DO THIS AND
I OR IS AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OF IT ON
THE SIDE OF. NINETEEN NINE
SENATOR MITCH WHICH ARE TOO
CLOSE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER PRESIDENT  WOULD I
AGREE WIH MY COLLEAGUE- FROM
THE SAN FRANCISCO AREA THAT
THIS IS NOT ONLY DOWN PAYMENT
OF STATE DOLLARS BUT SHOULD BE
PERCEIVED. AS A DOWN PAYMENT IN
TERMS OF OUR EXPECTATION OF
PUBLIC RESOURCES ACROSS THE
BOARD THAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT SHOULD ALSO BE
EXPECTED TO STEP UP IN A
MEANINGFUL AND SIGNIFICANT WAY.
TO HELP THE NUMBER ONE DONOR
STATE ON BAIL OUR WAY OUT OF
THIS INTERNATIONAL CRISIS BASED
ON COMMENTS MADE BY SOME OF THE
PEOPLE ON THE FLOOR I JUST WANT
TO DRAW YOUR ATTENTION- TO
LEGISLATIVE INTENT LANGUAGE-
NOTED ON- BUT THE THIRD PAGE OF
THE BILL AND IT READS AS
FOLLOWS. IT IS THE INTENT OF
THE LEGISLATURE THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION WORK WITH
STAKEHOLDERS INCLUDING MEMBERS
OF THE LEGISLATURE LEGISLATIVE
STAFF IN DEVELOPING STRATEGIES.
TO BE CONSIDERED FOR INCLUSION
IN THE BUDGET ACTIVE TWENTY
TWENTY TO ASSIST INDIVIDUALS
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS. AND
SMALL BUSINESSES EXPERIENCING
ECONOMIC HARDSHIPS DUE TO THE
IMPACT OF COAL BUT NINETEEN IT
IS OUR INTENTION AS WE CONTINUE
OUR DELIBERATIONS. FOR THE
UPCOMING BUDGET AX THE BUDGET
ACT OF TWENTY TWENTY. THAT THIS
WORK WILL CONTINUE TO BE
DISCUSSED AND APPROPRIATE
INVESTMENTS MADE IN KEEPING
CALIFORNIA OF FLOW. AND BEYOND
THAT THRIVING WITH THAT I ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE ON CONCURRENT FOR
SENATE BILL EIGHTY NINE. THANK
YOU SEEN ON DEBATE HAVING
INCLUDED SIR TERRY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALLEN HI ARCHULETA
AYE ATKINS AYE BATES BELL
BARGES HI BRADFORD HI CAMBIADO
HI CHIANG AYE DALY AYE DODD. I
DID ALSO HI GALGIANI AYE GLAZER
ON A GONZALEZ. GROVE HI
HERTZBERG HI HILL HI WES SO HI
TYLER HI JACKSON. JONES HI
LEYVA HI MCGUIRE HI MITCHELL HI
MONNING HI MORE LOCK HIGH
MORALE. NIELSEN PAN AYE
PORTANTINO AYE ROTH HI RUBIO
AYE SKINNER STERN HI AMBERG
HIGHWAY CASKEY HI WINNER HI
WILK. HI ICE. THIRTY TWO NO
ZERO THE SIMPLY MOMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. MOVING ON NOW TO
FILE ITEM SIXTY SEVEN SB ONE
SEVENTEEN SENATOR MITCHELL
YOU'RE PREPARED. MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE RICK. SENATE
BILL ONE SEVENTEEN BY THE
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND FISCAL
REVIEW AT ACT RELATING TO
EDUCATION FINANCE AND MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION THEREFORE TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BILL RELATED
TO THE BUDGET. SENATOR MITCHELL.
CALLING THIS MANY BY OUR
EXPERIENCE MANY OF US ARE
EXPERIENCING SCHOOL DISTRICTS
ACROSS THIS STATE MAKING THE
DIFFICULT DECISION TO CLOSE
THEIR DOORS AND SEND SCHOOL
CHILDREN HOME FOREIGN.
UNFORESEEN AMOUNT OF TIME IT'S
IMPORTANT WE FAVORABLY CONSIDER
THIS MESSAGE THIS MEASURE
SENATE BILL ONE SEVENTEEN AGAIN
BACK FOR CONCURRENT SINCE THE
EDUCATION TRAILER BILL THAT
CONTAINS STATUTORY CHANGES TO
THE TWENTY NINETEEN BUDGET ACT.
TO ADDRESS THE GOVERNOR'S MARCH
SECOND MARCH FOURTH TWENTY
TWENTY PROCLAMATION A. B.
EMERGENCY RELATED TO CALL THAT
NINETEEN. THE BILL DOES THE
FOLLOWING IT ENSURES THAT LOCAL
EDUCATION AGENCIES CONTINUE TO
RECEIVE FUNDING FOR A FULL
SCHOOL YEAR REGARDLESS OF
CLOSURES DUE TO A COLBERT
NINETEEN. THIS INCLUDES
APPORTIONMENT MADE ON THE BASIS
OF AVERAGE DAILY ATTENDANCE
FUNDING FOR THE AFTER SCHOOL
EDUCATION SAFETY PROGRAM AND
THE WAIVER OF PENALTIES RELATED
TO INSTRUCTIONAL DAY AND MINUTE
REQUIREMENTS. IT APPROPRIATE TO
ONE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS A
ONE TIME PROP NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FUND FOR LOCAL
EDUCATION AGENCIES TO PURCHASE
PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT. AND
PROVIDE SUPPLIES AND LABOR.
RELATED TO CLEANING SCHOOL
SITES. IT PROVIDES TIME
EXTENSIONS FOR STUDENTS
SUSSMAN'S AND A VARIETY OF
OTHER EDUCATIONAL REQUIREMENTS
I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON
CONCURRENT. THE NEW PORTANTINO.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT AND
MEMBERS I RISE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB ONE SEVENTEEN-
COMPLEMENT THE GOVERNOR FOR
HIS- ACTION ON HELPING SCHOOLS
HAVE CERTAINTY AS THIS BUDGET
YEAR AND SCHOOL YEAR PROGRESSES
WITH A LOT OF UNCERTAINTY I
ALSO WANT TO COMPLIMENT OUR
APPROACH HIM AND BUDGET CHAIR-
FOR GETTING THIS BILL TO THE
FLOOR TODAY SO WE CAN TAKE THIS
ACTION.BUT IN ADDITION I WANT
TO COMPLIMENT ALL OF THOSE
SCHOOL DISTRICT SCHOOL BOARD
MEMBERS AND SUPERINTENDENTS
MANY OF WHOM TOOK ACTION BEFORE
IT WAS ANNOUNCED THAT THEY WERE
GONNA BE REMAIN WHOLE- THEY
WERE WRESTLING WITH THE SSUE
OF PUTTING CHILDREN SAFETY
FIRST AND NOT HAVING TO SAY
WE'RE GONNA PUT KIDS IN HARM'S
WAY BECAUSE OF BUDGETARY
CONCERNS IN THOSE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS THAT DID THE RIGHT
THING ALSO RIVER DESERVE TO BE
COMMENDED BECAUSE THIS IS A
CASE WHERE. EVERYONE CAME
TOGETHER TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR
CHILDREN WERE SAFE OUR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ARE HOLE AND WE CAN
GET THROUGH THIS UNPRECEDENTED-
PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS SO I
STRONGLY URGE SUPPORT OF SB ONE
SEVENTEEN THANK YOU SENATOR
GIRL. THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT I TO HAVE- RISE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS EDUCATION
TRAILER BILL. AGAIN IT'S JUST
THINGS THAT I DON'T THINK THAT
WE HAVE THOUGHT AS I KNOW THAT
MAKING SURE THAT THE SCHOOLS
ARE MADE WHOLE THAT THERE'RE
MANY IN THERE THE FOR THE
RESOURCES CONTINUE- I GOT A
TEXT FROM A TEACHER THAT HAS
TWO YOUNG KIDS THAT IS GONNA BE
REQUIRED TO GO TO SCHOOL. AND
TAKERS YOUNG KIDS WITH HER TO
SCHOOL TO FACILITATE THE
PROCESS OF MAKING SURE THERE'S
OTHER STUDENTS ARE KATE SAFE
WHEN SHE DOESN'T HAVE DAY CARE
FOR HER OWN CHILDREN AND SHE
STILL REQUIRED TO GO. SO I
THINK THERE'S A LOT OF THINGS
THAT WE DO HERE- WITHOUT FULL
VETTING AND AGAIN WE HAVE TO
ACT IN AN EMERGENCY SITUATION
BUT I THINK THAT WE NEED TO
HAVE LONGER DISCUSSIONS. ABOUT
HOW IT ACTUALLY WORKS ON THE
GROUND AND OUR TEACHERS ARE
TAKING CARE OF AND- TAKE CARE
OF THEIR OWN FAMILIES AS WELL.
ANOTHER THING IS THAT YOU KNOW
A LOT OF OUR SCHOOL DISTRICTS
ARE OPERATING REMOTELY AND ONE
OF THE BARRIERS OF OPERATING
REMOTELY AND NOT HAVING
STUDENTS THERE WAS THE FISCAL
IMPACT OF THE MISSING DAYS. BUT
ANOTHER ISSUE THAT WE HAVE
OPERATING REMOTELY IS A LOT OF
OUR MAJORITY MINORITY DISTRICTS
IN A POOR COMMUNITIES EVEN IN
MY DISTRICT DON'T HAVE CRIME
NOTEBOOKS. SO STUDENTS CAN'T
OPERATE THEY DON'T EVEN HAVE A
LAPTOP AT HOME SO HOW DID THEY
PARTICIPATE WHERE DO THEY GO-
SO ALL I WHERE I SEE HOW- WE
ARE TRYING TO MEET THE NEEDS OF
ALMOST ALL STUDENTS. WE ARE
FAILING TO MEET THE NEEDS OF
SOME STUDENTS AND I'D LIKE THAT
DISCUSSION TO CONTINUE BUT IN
THE MEANTIME I THINK THIS IS A
VERY GOOD START- MAKING SURE
THAT OUR EDUCATION SYSTEM IS
MADE WHOLE. THANK YOU. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION ON THE BAIT
ON THIS ITEM. HEARING SEEN ON
SENATOR MATURE YOU MAY CLOSE I
WOULD STRONGLY ENCOURAGE AN AYE
VOTE ON CONCURRENCE AND SB ONE
SEVENTEEN FOR CALIFORNIA'S
CHILDREN. THANK YOU SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN HI
ARCHULETA I ATKINS BATES BELL
GORGEOUS HI BRADFORD HI
CAMBIADO HI CHIANG AYE DALY AYE
DODD. HI THERE ALSO I GALGIANI
AYE GLAZER HI GROW A GONZALEZ.
GROVE HI HERTZBERG AYE HILL HI
WES SO. HI RICARDO HI JACKSON
JONES I LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE AYE
MITCHELL. HI MONNING HI MORE
LOCK HI BROWN NIELSEN PAN HI
PORTANTINO HI ROSS HI RUBIO HI
SKINNER. STERN HI I'M- FIVE
CASKEY HI WIENER AYE WILK HI.
HI IS THIRTY ONE KNOWS ZERO THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS ARE CONCURRED
IN. MOVING BACK TO MOTIONS
WROTE RESOLUTIONS. WITHOUT
OBJECTION MEASURES REPORTED
DURING RESEARCH ON.
MEMBERS
WERE RETURN IT MOTIONS
RESOLUTIONS NOW'S THE TIME FOR
DURING A MEMORY SENATOR GLAZER
ARE YOU PREPARED FOR YOUR
JOURNEY MEMORY. FOR YOURS.
OBVIOUS THAT. GLAZER FLOORS
YOURS THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT MEMBERS- WITH GREAT
SADNESS I ASK THE SENATE TO
INJURED AND IN MEMORY OF LUCY
GEEK OF H. WHO PASSED AWAY LAST
WEEK AFTER A LONG AND BRAVE
BOUT WITH PANCREATIC CANCER.
LUCY WAS AN IMPACTFUL POLITICAL
PLAYER HERE IN SACRAMENTO
DURING THE FIRST AND SECOND
TERMS OF THOUGHT HE
MINISTRATION OF GOVERNOR. JERRY
BROWN. A BILL PRESS TWO HEADED
THE OFFICE OF PLANNING AND
RESEARCH AT THAT TIME. WHAT A
BEAUTIFUL. OBITUARY ABOUT LUCY
AS PART I THE SECOND BEE. AND
HE SAID THAT POLICY WAS NEVER
ELECTED GOVERNOR. FOR THOSE OF
US WHO SERVED IN SACRAMENTO
DURING JERRY BROWN'S FIRST
EIGHT YEARS AS GOVERNOR.
THERE'S NO DOUBT WHO IS
ACTUALLY RUNNING THE SHOW. IT
WAS NOT BROWN. NOR ANY TOP AIDE
REMEMBER THE CABINET. IT WAS
THE GOVERNOR'S EXECUTIVE
ASSISTANT LUCY. AND HE GOES ON
TO SAY THAT SHE HAD A DESK
RIGHT OUTSIDE THE GOVERNOR'S
PRIVATE OFFICE. AND SHE WAS AN
AMAZING UNFLAPPABLE SUPER
ORGANIZED. TWENTY FIVE YEAR OLD
YOUNG WOMAN YES TWENTY FIVE
YEARS OLD WHO HELD IT ALL
TOGETHER WITH THE STEADY FORCE
WELL BEYOND HER YEARS. I MET
SAYS LUCY IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
ONE WHEN SHE AGREED TO LEAVE
THE ADMINISTRATION AND BECOME
THE PRESS SECRETARY FOR
GOVERNOR BROWN'S CAMPAIGN FOR
THE UNITED STATES SENATE. WHERE
I WAS WORKING. I SHE WAS A
GRIZZLED VETERAN AT THE RIPE
OLD AGE OF THIRTY ONE. WHO TOOK
THIS YOUNG CUB UNDER HER WING
WITH GREAT. LOVE AND AFFECTION.
LUCY HAD A GREAT CAREER AN
EXCEPTIONAL CAREER AFTER
LEAVING THE BROWN
ADMINISTRATION. SHE WENT TO
WORK FOR PETER UEBERROTH AND
THE NINETEEN EIGHTY FOUR SUMMER
OLYMPICS IN LOS ANGELES THE
INFORMATION THE BASEBALL AND
THEN AS A SENIOR EXECUTIVE FOR
PACIFIC BELL. LUCY AND HER
BUSINESS PARTNER DAN CRAIN.
FOUNDED A SUCCESSFUL LOBBYING
FIRM THAT BECAME PROMINENT.
HERE IN SACRAMENTO AND IN
WASHINGTON DC AND THEIR CLIENTS
WERE A GREAT BLUE CHIP LIST OF
PUBLIC AND PRIVATE ENTITIES. I
HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO TALK
WITH JURY BROWN TODAY ANY
SHARED SOME THOUGHTS WITH ME
ABOUT LUCY. HE SAID. SHE
EXAMPLE FIGHT POLITICS
IRRESPECTIVE OF PARTY. THE WAY
IT USED TO BE FOR MANY. SHE HAD
FRIENDS FROM BOTH PARTIES A
LESSON PEOPLE NEED TO RE
LEARNED SHE WAS EVER GIVING AND
LOYAL FRIEND. AT LUCY'S
WONDERFUL ACCOMPLISHMENTS WERE
JUST LISTED ON A RESUME HE
LOVED TO TALK POLITICS WAS A
DEVOTED FRIEND LOVED TO LAUGH.
HAD A TERRIFIC SENSE OF HUMOR
AND THERE WAS NO BETTER LUNCH
OR DINNER COMPANION THAN LUCY.
SHE HAD THAT. UNUSUAL TRAIT OF
BEGINNING A CONVERSATION IN THE
MIDDLE OF A PARAGRAPHAND FOR
THOSE WHO KNOW HER WELL THEY
LAUGHED AT THAT BUT- SHE HAD
HER HAND ON THE PULSE OF
POLITICS AND SHE KNEW THAT YOU
DID AND SEATED AT THE START
WITH THE BASICS JUST GOT RIGHT
INTO THE- GOSSIPING TODAY. A
CLOSE FRIEND OF LUCY'S- JAMIE
CALLAHAN WROTE ON HER FACEBOOK
PAGE. DESCRIBING LUCY IS
MAGICAL AND MYSTERIOUS WHO
FLOATED AROUND THE WORLD. AND
YOU NEVER WERE SURE WHERE SHE
WOULD TURN UP NEXT. WILL BE
SERVICES FOR LUCY IN WASHINGTON
DC LATER THIS MONTH. AT A
CELEBRATION OF HER LIFE HERE IN
SACRAMENTO LATER THIS SPRING-
WE MISS YOU AND LOVE YOU LUCY I
CANNOT WAIT TO SEE WHERE YOU'RE
GOING TO TURN UP NEXT. AND I
KNOW THEY'LL BE A WONDERFUL
TWINKLE IN YOUR EYE WITH THAT I
ASKED THAT WE THE JOURNEY
WONDERFUL MEMORY. SENATOR THANK
YOU FOR THAT VERY PERSONAL. AN
ELOQUENT ADJOURN. WE'RE GONNA
LOOK TO CENTERS LETTER ON THIS
ITEM SIR. INITIALLY THE FLOOR
IS YOURS. MISTER PRESIDENT
THANK YOU I RISE IN ALSO IN
MEMORY LUCY IS AS- MY CHIEF OF
STAFF DON WILCOX HAD A REALLY
REALLY GREAT RELATIONSHIP
WHETHER AS YOU KNOW DON WILL
**** HAD BEEN IN THIS BEAUTIFUL
CHAMBER AND BUILDING FOR OVER
TWENTY SEVEN YEARS SO HE WAS
ABLE TO. MAKE A GREAT FRIEND IN
LUCY AND HE WANTED ME TO MAKE
SURE THAT- ALL OF SHOULD
UNDERSTOOD NICK KNOWLEDGE THAT
THE SHE WAS  FRIEND TO SO MANY
BUT ESPECIALLY TO DON WILCOX
AND- DON YOU'VE YOU'VE LOST A
GOOD FRIEND. AND I JUST WANT TO
POINT OUT THAT HE HAD MENTIONED
THAT HE WAS BORN AND RAISED IN
MONTEBELLO IN MY DISTRICT AND
SHE EVEN RAN FOR CITY COUNCIL
BACK IN MONTEBELLO SO IF YOU
FILE- FOLLOW HER TRAIL SHE
ALWAYS WOULD LEAD RIGHT HERE
BACK TO THE CAPITAL BUT SHE
TOUCHED SO MANY. DON WENT ON TO
SAY THAT HE WAS A PASSIONATE
INDIVIDUAL SHE CARE FOR
EVERYONE HE WAS KIND AND SHE
ENCOUNTERED SO MANY FRIENDS
ALONG THE WAY AND IT WAS CLEAR
TO ALL WHO MET HER THAT THEY
LOVED- THEY GOT TO ADMIRE HER
AND DON WILCOX. YOUR GOOD
FRIEND HAS BEEN LOST WHICH WILL
NEVER BE FORGOTTEN AND SHE WILL
BE SORELY MISSED THANK YOU.
PRESIDENT THANK YOU MISTER
SENATOR. THIRD GRADERS BRINGING
THE OFFICIAL GERMAN REQUESTS UP
TO THE DESK. MEMBERS WE LOST A
GREAT ONE- FEW WEEKS AGO
CEREMONY THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. MEMBERS I RISE TODAY
TO ASK THAT WE ADJOURN IN THE
MEMORY OF FORMER ASSEMBLYMEMBER
CUT CHAU ASIDE JIAN WHO DIED ON
MARCH FIFTH. CUT TO REPRESENTED
THE THIRTY FIFTH ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT WHICH INCLUDES ALL OF
SAN LUIS OBISPO COUNTY WHICH I
ALSO REPRESENT I FIRST MET
CACHO WHEN WE BOTH SERVED IN
THE ASSEMBLY AND WE CONTINUE TO
COLLABORATE AFTER MY ELECTION
TO THE SENATE. CULTURE WAS BORN
ANGELA LEBANON IN NINETEEN
FIFTY ONE TO ARMENIAN PARENTS.
CUT CHAU IMMIGRATED TO THE
UNITED STATES IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY ONE. AND BECAME A US
CITIZEN IN NINETEEN EIGHTY TWO.
I CHOSE STORY IS AN AMERICAN
SUCCESS STORY HE ATTENDED QUEST
TO COMMUNITY COLLEGE AND
TRANSFERRED TO CAL POLY.
GRADUATED WITH A BUSINESS
ADMINISTRATION DEGREE. CATCH A
BECAME A PILLAR OF THE BUSINESS
COMMUNITY IN ARROYO GRANDE CORY
OPENED HIS FIRST OF THREE GAS
STATIONS IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
EIGHT. KOCH WAS FIRST ELECTED
TO THE SENATE OBISPO COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN
NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT WHERE HE
SERVED FOR THREE TERMS IN
TWENTY TEN CUT SHE WAS ELECTED
TO THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSEMBLY. PERSON AT THIRTY
THIRTY D. THEN AND THE THIRTY
FIFTH EIGHTY AFTER THE TWENTY
ELEVEN REDISTRICTING HE SERVED
FOR THREE TERMS IN THE ASSEMBLY
AND CONTINUE TO BE ACTIVE IN
THE COMMUNITY. AFTER THE END OF
HIS TERM. AMONG CULTURES OTHER
CIVIC ROLES HE SERVED ON THE
BOARDS OF THE OR RAIL GRANDE
COMMUNITY HOSPITAL IN THE SAN
LUIS OBISPO FRENCH HOSPITAL HE
WAS APPOINTED BY GOVERNOR PETE
WILSON. TO SERVE ON THE SLOW
COUNTY FAIR BOARD AND LATER BY
GOVERNOR SCHWARZENEGGER TO THE
CALIFORNIA COASTAL COMMISSION.
CUT CHAU SERGEANT WAS A PUBLIC
MAN. A PUBLIC SERVANT WHO VOTED
HIS CONSCIENCE TO SERVE THE
INTEREST OF HIS CONSTITUENTS.
IN RECOGNITION OF HIS SERVICE
CUT TO RECEIVED MANY AWARDS AND
RECOGNITIONS. MOST RECENTLY
CAUGHT CHAU WORKED WITH
STUDENTS AT CAL POLY TO SPONSOR
A BILL I CARRIED LAST YEAR TO
CREATE GREATER TRANSPARENCY
RELATED TO COSTS FOR
PERSPECTIVE SEE ISSUE AND YOU
SEE STUDENTS. CAL POLY STUDENTS
TESTIFIED IN SUPPORT OF THAT
LEGISLATION AND THE BILL WAS
SIGNED INTO LAW. CUT CHAU LED
THAT EFFORT AND WAS SO PROUD TO
SEE HIS STUDENTS TESTIFYING
HERE IN THE STATE ACCOUNTS IN
THE STATE LEGISLATURE WITH KAT
SHOW SERVING AS THEIR MENTOR.
PEOPLE DIDN'TLIKE CAUGHT CHAU
THEY LOVED HIM FOR GOOD REASON
SAID THE CHAIRMAN OF THE
ARMENIAN NATIONAL COMMITTEE OF
AMERICA IN RESPONSE TO NEWS OF
CAUGHT SHOWS DEATH. CULTURE WAS
A PUBLIC SERVANT IN A PUBLIC
MAN HE WAS BELOVED BY THE
PEOPLE AND COMMUNITIES HE
REPRESENTED BUT WAS ALWAYS
QUICK TO REMIND PEOPLE. THAT HE
DREW HIS INSPIRATION FOR HIS
WORK FROM HIS LOVE FOR HIS WIFE
FOR ROXY. IN HIS SON HER RANCH
IN HIS DAUGHTER NAIRI. I KNOW
THAT MANY OF MY COLLEAGUES IN
THE SENATE. NEW AND SERVED WITH
CUT CHAU. MANY OF OUR SENATE
FAMILY WERE ALSO PRESENT AT THE
FUNERAL SERVICES LAST FRIDAY IN
SAN LUIS OBISPO ALONG WITH
ASSEMBLY COLLEAGUES FROM BOTH
SIDES OF THE AISLE. HIS LEGACY
HERE IN IN THIS DISTRICT WILL
HAVE STRONG AS CUT CHAU
EXEMPLIFIED THE BEST OF A
PUBLIC SERVANT. WE TREATED
EVERYONE WITH RESPECT AND WAS
NOT TO FOR FREIGHT TO TAKE AN
UNPOPULAR POSITION IF HE FELT
TO BE IN THE BEST INTEREST OF
HIS CONSTITUENTS. COLLEAGUES
PLEASE JOIN ME AS WE ADJOURN
TODAY IN THE MEMORY OF CAUGHT
CHOI IDE SHE IN I KNOW MANY
WILL HAD COMMENTS. I JUST KNOW
PERSONALLY I WILL MISS SCOTT
SHOW IN THOSE THAT WERE ABLE TO
ATTEND THE FUNERAL. HIS
CHILDREN DID HIM PROUD THEY
WERE VERY COURAGEOUS IN
SHARING. VERY STRONG AND
PERSONAL MEMORIES ABOUT KAT
SHOW- THERE WAS A HUGE
COMMUNITY TURN OUT TO SAY
GOODBYE. TO OUR FRIEND CAUGHT
CHAU THANK YOU. IT'S OUR MONEY
THANK YOU. BOTH A FRIEND AND A
COLLEAGUE TO CEREMONY. WE'D
LIKE TO TURN THE FLOOR OVER TO
SENATOR BRADFORD BRADFORD AND
WE'RE GONNA GO TO LEADER GROVE.
PORTANTINO CENTER DOLLY CENTER
HUESO IN CENTER MITCHELL.
CENTER BRADFORD THE FLOORS OR
SIR THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
I TO RISE TODAY WITH GREAT
SADNESS TO ADJOURN. IN MEMORY.
NOT ONLY A GREAT COLLEAGUE A
GREAT HUSBAND. AN AMAZING
FATHER. AND JUST A GREAT HUMAN
BEING AND THAT AND CUT TO A
SHOT IN. I HAD THE HONOR OF
SERVING WITH CACHO IN THE STATE
ASSEMBLY. I MET CACHO TEN YEARS
AGO AS A SWARTS BEING SWORN IN
AND I WAS ASSESSING THAT
INCOMING CLASS AND I SAID. WHO
WOULD I HAVE SOMETHING IN
COMMON WITH CUT TO A SHOT JUNE
WAS THE LAST PERSON I
CONSIDERED I WOULD HAVE
ANYTHING IN COMMON WITH HE AS
A REPUBLICAN. FROM THE CENTRAL
COAST. BUSINESSMAN WITH THIS
BIG HEAVY ACCENT. BUT IT WAS-NOT UNTIL I WAS WORKING A BILL
ONE DAY AND I WAS A FEW VOTES
SHORT. AND SPEAKER PERES WALKED
OVER TO ME SAYS HAVE YOU TALKED
TO CULTURE SHOCK TO ASSIST NO
WHY WOULD I TALK TO CACHO HE'S
NOT GONNA VOTE FOR THIS USES.
BRADFORD YOU'LL BE AMAZED HOW
THE CONVERSATION. THAT'S WHAT I
DID I WALKED OVER NOT ONLY THE
REYES FROM HIS DESK TO LOOK ME
IN THE HIGH. AND HE LISTENED TO
THE ISSUE AND HE SAYS. I'LL GO
UP AND IF I CAN HELP I WOULD.
THAT'S TO COST JOE WAS USE A
GUY WHO. IN LET PARTY POLITICS
GET IN THE WAY. HE WAS
INDIVIDUAL WHO CAME TO THIS
COUNTRY AT NINETEEN A IMMIGRANT
NOT LOOKING FOR A HANDOUT BUT
LOOKING FOR AN OPPORTUNITY HE
LIVED HIS LIFE BY MATTHEW SEVEN
CHAPTER SEVEN VERSE SEVEN SEEK
AND YOU SHALL FIND. KNOCK NHL
LANCER HE CAME HERE SEEKING AN
OPPORTUNITY HE CAME HERE
SEEKING A EDUCATION WHAT MAKES
AMERICA GREAT IS THE
OPPORTUNITIES THAT THIS COUNTRY
PROVIDES NOT ONLY THOSE WHO
WERE BORN HERE BUT INDIVIDUALS
LIKE CUT TO A SHOT YET WHO CAME
HERE HE CAME HERE SPEAKING
KNOWING ENGLISH ANY LEARNED
ENGLISH BY WORKING AT A SERVICE
STATION. DR MARTIN LUTHER KING
STATE WE CAN ALL BE GREAT
BECAUSE WE CONSERVE CUT TO LIVE
THE LIFE OF SERVICE HE STARTED
AS A SERVANT ATTENDED PUMPING
GAS CHECKING THE ERROR IN YOUR-TIRE WHEN WE GET FULL SERVICE
GAS STATIONS MAKING SURE YOUR
OIL WAS. OF FULL IN YOUR CAR
AND WASHING YOUR WINDOWS. HE
ATTENDED SCHOOL STRAIGHT FROM
WORK NEVER CHANGES UNIFORM AND
GO STRAIGHT. TO A COMMUNITY
COLLEGE THEN ON DECALS STATE.
ARMY OUT. SAN LUIS OBISPO. HE
WAS THE INDIVIDUAL WHO BELIEVE
IN WORKING IN GIVING BACK TO
HIS COMMUNITY HE WAS A TRUE
PUBLIC SERVANT AND THE WORDS HE
WAS AS STATED LOVE BY ALL THAT
HE ENCOUNTERED BECAUSE HE LOVED
ALL THOSE BADDIES HE
ENCOUNTERED I TOOK GREAT JOY
AND HANGING OUT WITH CACHO
KATSU AND I WOULD MAKE THE
ROUNDS EVERY EVENING TO THE
VARIOUS EVENTS BUT WHAT STOOD
OUT ALSO WAS CUT TO WAS THE
CONSUMMATE. GENTLEMAN IF THERE
WAS A FEMALE STAFF MEMBER OR
THIRD HOUSE IN OUR PRESENCE
THEY COULD NEVER OPEN A DOOR.
THEY COULD NEVER PAY FOR BILL.
AND CUT TO THEN DO THIS TO BE
BURKE BRAGGADOCIO AS MANY TIMES
HE WOULD SLIP HIS CREDIT CARD
TO A WAITRESS OR A BARTENDER
AND PAY A STAFF SPILL
UNBEKNOWNST TO THEM. IF IT WAS
LATE AT NIGHT AND IT WAS FEMALE
STAFFERS NEEDED A RIDE BACK TO
WERE THEIR CAR WAS PARKED CUT
TO WOULD ARRANGE A CAR AND MAKE
SURE. THAT THEY GOT BACK SAFELY.
HE IT WAS THOSE TYPE OF THINGS
COP TWO WOULD ALWAYS MAKE SURE
THAT IF HE HAD MEMBERS IN FROM
HIS DISTRICT. IT WAS A BRADFORD
I WANT YOU TO MEET MY SHARE. I
WANT YOU TO MEET MEMBERS FROM
MY CHAMBER OF COMMERCE. I WANT
YOU TO MEET THE VARIOUS PEOPLE
OF MY COMMUNITY AT ALL THOSE
INDIVIDUALS. LOVED CACHO CUT TO
EVEN. SET ME UP ON A BLIND DATE.
IT IS HEREBY ME TO MEET MEET
MEET ONE NIGHT AND- BUT NOTES
TO ME IT WAS A BLIND DATE AND
THOUGH IT WAS THAT THE LOVE
CONNECTION THAT CAUGHT TO IT
HOPE FOR IT WAS A FRIENDSHIP
THAT IS ONGOING TO THIS DAY SO
MUCH SO THAT IT WAS I WHO
CAUGHT TIS INDIVIDUAL A MATE
OR WHERE. THAT CLOUT TO IT
PASSED TWO WEEKS AGO. THAT WAS
THE KIND OF GUY CUT TO A SHOT
JUNIORS. HE ALSO TEXT ME ONE
DAY WHILE I WAS OUT OF THE
SIMPLY AND HE SHOWED ME A
PICTURE OF A ROAD SIGN THREE
FOOT BIKE LAYING GIVING THREE
FEET TO BICYCLES OF THE PIECE
OF LEGISLATION I PASSED. AND
THE LEGISLATURE I AM ASSEMBLY I
SHOULD TO. AND HE TAX MANY SAYS
I APOLOGIZE AT A ROCK SEE AND I
DIDN'T TAKE A SELFIE UNDER
THIS- SIGN. WAS IS THE NARROW
ROAD AND EVERYBODY SPEEDING.
CUT TO A SHOT IN WAS WORRIED
ABOUT EVERY BY SPEEDING IF YOU
KNEW ANYTHING ABOUT CUT TO HE
HAD A LEAD FOOT. WE USED TO
REGALE IN THE STORIES THAT HE
WOULD TELL JOHN PER RED COPY
WAS SOLD KNOWN ON THAT ROUTE
FROM. SAN LUIS OBISPO TO
SACRAMENTO THAT HIGHWAY PATROL
STOP. STOPPING HIM. THEY
PROVIDED. TECHNICALLY
UNOFFICIAL ESCORTS THEY WOULD.
SEEK OUT TO DO BESIDE A MORE
DINNER FRONT ON THE SLOWING
DOWN THE SEVENTY FIVE IT MAKES
YOUR HE GOT HERE BUT THEY THEY
KNEW GOD TO WORK OUT TO LOVE TO
DRIVE FAST- I CAN GO ON AND ON
AND- ABOUT. MY FRIENDSHIP WITH
THIS DEAR MAN. ON THE LAST
NIGHT OF THE ASSEMBLY WE
DEDICATED TO PORTICO TO JOHN
PEREZ BECAUSE WE LOVED SMOKING
CIGARS OUT THERE BUT CUT TO WAS
REALLY THECHAIR OF THE CIGAR
CAUCUS. FOR THOSE WHO WANTED TO
COME OUT TO HAVE A GOOD TIME IF
YOU DIDN'T HAVE A CIGAR CAUGHT
TO PARTY THE BEST CIGARS HE-
MANAGED TO FIND. CUBAN CIGARS
AT A TIME WHEN WE WEREN'T
SUPPOSED STAFF CUBAN CIGARS CUT
TO WAS THAT KIND OF GUY HE WAS
GENEROUS. TO A FAULT. HE GAVE
OF HIMSELF. THAT'S WHY IT WAS
LOVE HE IS LOVED I CAN STAND
HERE AND SAY. NOT ONLY DO I
TRULY LOVE CUT TO A SHOT CHEN I
KNOW KOCH WAS SERGEANT. LET ME
HE NEVER FELT ASKED ABOUT MY
MOTHER ANYTIME. WE GOT
TOGETHER. AND LIKE YOU SAID. HE
WILL BE MISSED BY THIS
INSTITUTION HE'LL BE MISSED BY
THIS COMMUNITY. MORE
IMPORTANTLY HE'LL BE MISSED BY
ALL THOSE THAT HE TOUCHED HIS
WHAT MADE AMERICA GREAT HE WAS
A GREAT AMERICAN HE WAS A GREAT
FRIEND HE WAS A FANTASTIC
BECAUSE MEN TO A ROCK SEE. TO
HIS SON HORROCKS AND HIS
DAUGHTER NAIROBI AND ONE OF THE
BIGGEST HONOR SHE GAVE ME WAS
INVITING ME PERSONALLY TO HIS
SON'S WEDDING. A NUMBER YEARS
AGO AT I WANT TO THANK THE
PROTEOME FOR FORTY ME. THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ATTEND HIS
FUNERAL LAST WEEKTHAT WAS THE
FIRST. PAY THAT I MISSED
LEGISLATIVE SESSION IN NINE
YEARS HERE BUT IT WAS IMPORTANT
MAY BECAUSE I KNOW IF IT WAS
THE OTHER WAY AROUND CAUGHT TWO
WOULD HAVE BEEN THERE FOR ME. I
THANK YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY.
THEREAFTER THAT WAS BEAUTIFUL.
AND HE STARTED THE STATEMENT
SAYING THE HIS KIDS MADE THE
SUMMERS FAMILY PROUD YOU JUST
MADE THEM PROUD AS WELL. THANK
YOU. WE LIKE TO TURN THE FLOOR
OVER LEADER GROW. THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT I TOO WOULD
LIKE TO JOIN MY COLLEAGUES AND
ADJOURNMENT WITH A HEAVY HEART-
IN. ADJOURNING IN THE MEMORY OF
AN INCREDIBLE FATHER BUSINESS
OWNER VOLUNTEER PUBLIC SERVANT
AND FRIEND CUT TO A SHOT IN. A
CUT TO A SHORT WORK FOR CAKE
CHECK WHICH IN ARMENIAN MEANS
LITTLE CROSS. AND WHEN YOU
THINK ABOUT KOCH'S PERSONALITY
AND WHO HE WAS WHEN HE TALKED
ABOUT THE CROSS IT'S ABOUT AND
CONDITIONAL LEFT. AND THERE IS
NO DOUBT THAT ALL OF US THAT
WORKED WITH CACHO KNOWS THAT HE
REPRESENTED AND CONDITIONAL
LOVE DIDN'T MATTER WHO IT WAS
OR WHO WE ENGAGED WITH- EVEN IF
HE WAS IN OPPOSITION HE ALWAYS
DID IT WITH AN AMAZING LOVE
THAT JUST TOUCH PEOPLE'S
HEARTS. CACHO IMMIGRATED TO
UNITED STTES FROM LEBANON IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY ONE TO FURTHER
IS EDUCATIONAL JOURNEY. HE
TOUCHES DRIVE WAS TRULY
DEMONSTRATED A WIN IT MEANS AND
DEMONSTRATED WHAT IT MEANS TO
BECOME AN AMERICAN TO PURSUE
THE AMERICAN DREAM. AFTER
ATTENDING COMMUNITY COLLEGE HE
PROUDLY BECAME A US CITIZEN HE
MARRIES BEAUTIFUL WIFE ROXIE OF
ROXY THEY WOULD LATER GO ON TO
THEIR DAUGHTER NINE THREE AND
ROCH HIS SON. CUT TO OPEN THE
BUSINESS IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
EIGHT WHEN HE PURCHASED ZERO
GRANDE SHELL STATION AND LATER
EXPANDED TO THREE SHELL
STATIONS IN THAT AREA. GIVING
BACK TO THE COMMUNITY WAS
IMPORTANT TO CACHO AND HE DID.
EVERYTHING THAT HE DID HE DID
AS A DEDICATED PUBLIC SERVANT.
CUT TO MAYBE IMPACTS SERVING
GOVERNMENT BOTH IN HIS COUNTY
LEVEL AND AT THE STATE LEVEL IN
DURING HIS TWO DECADES OF
PUBLIC SERVICE HE SERVED
COMMUNITIES IN COUNTLESS ROLES.
INCLUDING THE FEAR THE STATE
ASSEMBLYMAN FOR THE SAN LUIS
OBISPO COUNTY. EVEN AS A STATE
LEGISLATOR WITH MANY DUTIES AND
PRESSURES. CULTURE WAS NEVER
TOO BUSY EMPOWER USING GIVE
BACK TO THE COMMUNITY OR HELP
OTHERS ALL WITH A WARM GENEROUS
SPIRIT. JUST TO SHARE A COUPLE
OF PERSONAL STORIES. WE MET AT
THE TRAINING DAY WE ALL GOT PUT
IN TOGETHER IS. AS SENATOR
BRADFORD SAID AND WE GO TO THE
TRAINING DAY IN. AND THEN- IN
THE ELEVATOR AFTER TRAINING I
HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO MEET
CACHO AND HIS. FAMILY AND SO WE
HAVE TO PICTURE THIS AND YOU
GUYS WILL UNDERSTAND WHAT I'M
SAYING THE ELEVATOR DOOR OPENS.
AND HERE'S CACHO RATE HE'S GOT
THIS FLUFFY WHITE DOG IN HIS
ARMS. ANY AS THESE TWO
BEAUTIFUL TALL AMAZING LOOKING
WOMEN STANDING NEXT TO HIM. IN
A VERY HANDSOME SON. AND I SAID
OH HI IS THAT YOUR DOG AND ARE
THESE YOUR DAUGHTERS AND HE
GOES. HE WAS A SURE DODD
TALKING THE DAUGHTERS AND IS
THIS YOUR DAUGHTERS AND CATCH A
GOES NO IT'S MY DOG IN. THIS IS
MY WIFE AND MY DAUGHTER. SO HE
WAS REALLY PROUD OF HIS FAMILY
AND- WHO THEY WERE AND THEY
WERE AMAZING INDIVIDUALS AND
ROXY ROXY WAS. IS JUST A
BEAUTIFUL WOMAN WHO JUST ADORE
DEMAND THAT JUST GAVE HER.
UNCONDITIONAL ELEVEN METER FEEL
ABSOLUTELY AMAZING. AND I THINK
THAT SPEAKS VOLUMES FOR THE
HUSBAND AND THE FATHER THAT HE
WAS. I HAVE TO CONCUR WITH MY
COLLEAGUE. SENATOR BRADFORD- I
DO HAVE TO CONCUR THERE WAS A-
LONG STANDING JOKE BETWEEN
SENATOR FULLER WRESTLE AND I
THAT KOCH IT WOULD MAKE IT HOME
BEFORE JUDGE RUSSELL COULD FLY
JEAN AND I HOME. AND IT'S THE
SAME DISTANCE SO IT'S FIVE
HOURS TO BAKERSFIELD FIVE HOURS
TO SAN LUIS OBISPO. AND WE
WOULD GET IN THE PLANE BEFORE
WE WOULD TAKE OFF WE WOULD MAKE
JOKES THAT KOCH'S ALREADY
GETTING. INTO ST LOUIS SO THAT
IS NOT VERY FAR FROM THE TRUTH
OF HIS SPEED DEMON DRIVING. HE
WAS AN IMMIGRANT A PROUD
AMERICAN AND A FATHER. AND A
HUSBAND AND A FRIEND. AND I AM
HE TRULY EMBODIED WHAT I WOULD
SAY IS A STATESMAN. IN THE
CALIFORNIA STATE LEGISLATURE
AND HE WILL BE DEEPLY MISSED.
THE TO GROW THANK YOU. MEMBERS
WOULD LIKE TO TURN THE FLORIDA
CENTER PORTANTINO DURING THEIR
SENATOR DOLLY IN CENTER WASTE.
THANK YOU I MISS PRESIDENTE
MEMBERS AND- IT'S BEEN REALLY
NICE TO LISTEN TO THE COMMENTS
FROM SO MANY OF OUR COLLEAGUES
ABOUT THIS WONDERFUL MAN- CUT
YOUR CHARGING- HE TRULY WAS
EVERYTHING EVERYBODY SAYING. A
NICE MAN A SMART MAN A
GENTLEMANLY MAN AND SMEBODY
WHO YOU COULD ACTUALLY HAVE A
SINCERE RELATIONSHIP IN A CRAZY
BUSINESS CALL POLITICS ACROSS
THE AISLE. AND LONG AFTER I
LEFT THE ASSEMBLY HE WOULD TAX
THEN CHECK UP ON THINGS AND
INFORM ME OF WHAT'S GOING ON IT
WAS JUST ONE OF THOSE PEOPLE
THAT. DID THE EXTRA MILE AS IF
IT WAS SECOND NATURE- AND I
THINK THAT'S WHAT MADE HIM
SPECIAL AND HE WAS JUST DOING
IT BECAUSE- HE WAS JUST A GOOD
HEARTED SOUL. WHO CARED ABOUT.
THE INSTITUTION BUT CARED ABOUT
HIS FAMILY AND HIS DISTRICT IN
CALIFORNIA- WHICH GAVE HIM AN
OPPORTUNITY TO BE A SUCCESSFUL
BUSINESS PERSON ANY GAVE SO
MUCH OF HIS LIFE BACK. TO HIS
COMMUNITY AND SO- HONORED TO
HAVE KNOWN HIM. TO HAVE SERVED
WITH HIM TO GET TO KNOW HIS
FAMILY AND JUST TO NOW TRULY
WONDERFUL SPECIAL- INDIVIDUAL
WHO TOUCH SACRAMENTO SO WELL
YOU KNOW WE SAID THAT BLESSED
ARE THE PEACEMAKERS. FOR THEY
SHALL BE CALLED CHILDREN OF
GOD- CATCHER WAS ONE OF THOSE
PEOPLE WHO LOOK TO FIND COMMON
GROUND AND MAKE PEACE AND
CERTAINLY. WAS REWARDED IN THIS
WORLD AND I'M SURE IN THE NEXT
AND SO I'M PROUD TO- JOIN MY
SIN OR IN THE MEMORY OF CATCH
GEN. THANK YOU MUCH AND
PORTANTINO. THIRD ALL GETTING
THE FLOORS YOURS THANK YOU
MISTER. I ALSO HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO. SPEND FOUR
YEARS IN THE ASSEMBLY WITH
CACHO AND. EVERYTHING HAS BEEN
SAID YEARS TRUE TODAY THAT- HE
WAS A REALLY AMAZING HUMAN
BEING. I WANT TO SHARE JUST ONE
LITTLE SIDE STORY THAT TO I
NEVER SMOKED A CIGAR MY LIFE
UNTIL I CAME TO THE STATE
ASSEMBLY. AND NOW WE WERE AT
THE MAX. SPEAKER PREZ WAS THERE
pAND THEY ASKED ME IF I WANTED
TO SMOKE A CIGAR. I THOUGHT
WELL I GUESS I BETTER EVERYBODY
ELSE WAS SO I. SO ANYWAY THEY
LIVE HELP ME GET THE THING LET
AND ALL THE THINGS YOU'RE
SUPPOSED TO DO WITH THE C. R.
AND THEN. I SMOKED IT LIKE YOU
WOULD SMOKE A CIGARETTE I
INHALED IT. AND IT INSTANTLY
GAGGED ME AND I WAS COUGHING
AND CHOKING AND YOU KNOW COURSE
EVERYBODY THERE WAS LAUGHING
AND- AND CACHO WHEN E REALLY
GOT TICKLED HIS EYES WOULD
WATER AND FOR YEARS AFTER THAT
HE WOULD STILL TALK ABOUT THE
FIRST TIME I SMOKED A CIGAR.
BUT I WANT TO SHARE I WANT TO
FIRST THANK THE PRO TEMPER.
GIVING AYE RARELY MISSED DAYS
YOU'RE WAS WELL BUT- I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING US TO GO
PARRIS BACKS TO. A REALLY.
AMAZING HE WOULD BE. WHO WHO.
BY THE TURN OUT AND BY THE HE
WAS PROBABLY THE MOST LIKED
MEMBER OF THE ASSEMBLY CROSSBOW
SIZE OUT I DON'T KNOW ANYBODY
ELSE THAT WAS MORE WELL LIKED
IN CACHO SERGEANT AND I JUST
WANT TO SAY- TO IF HIS FAMILY
IS WATCHING THIS DATA. I HAD TO.
MY FATHER. ELEVEN YEARS AGO AND
I WANT TO REACH REACH OUT TO
BOTH- HIS DAUGHTER AND HIS HIS
SON WHO DID. THE MOST AMAZING
JOB. IN THAT RESPECT TO HIM AT
HIS SERVICE. IT IS VERY
DIFFICULT TO DO WHAT THEY DID
AND IT WAS A REAL TRIBUTE. TO
THEIR FATHER AND ALSO WANTED TO
SHARE THAT. NO ONE WHO I'M
SOMEBODY WHO BELIEVES AND I YOU
KNOW I'M I GET FRUSTRATED WITH
GOD. WHEN HE TAKES SOMEBODY AT
SIXTY EIGHT YEARS OLD WHO HAS
MANY MORE DAYS LEFT AND I
ALWAYS WONDER THAT'S SOMETHING
I WANT TO ASK GOD SOME DAYS WHY.
IF YOU TAKE THE GRAY ONES AND
SOME THAT ARE SO GREAT STAY
HERE LONGER BUT I THINK IT'S
BECAUSE- MAYBE. THAT HE WANTS
TO GET THEM THERE WITH HIM
BECAUSE THEY ARE HE WAS SUCH AN
AWESOME HUMAN BEING SO. I
WANTED TO SAY TO YOUR FAMILY IF
YOU'RE WATCHING. GREAT JOB I
KNOW IT'S HARD AND TOUGH. AND
WE WILL MISS YOUR DAD. AND YOUR
HUSBAND. AND HE WAS A GREAT MAN.
THANK YOU SO MUCH CENTER DOLLY.
MEMBERS GOOD EVENING SIR HUESO
FORESHORES. THANK YOU MISS
PRESIDENTE AND- I KNOW I CAN
TOP THOSE THOSE. EULOGIES BUT I
HAD TO RISE TO PAY RESPECTS TO
A REALLY GOOD FRIEND OF MINE I
MET CACHO ON THE COASTAL
COMMISSION. IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHT WE GOT TO SERVE TOGETHER.
AND IMMEDIATELY YOU KNOW I CAME
TO RESPECT HIM VERY MUCH AND
ADMIRE HIM. WHEN WHENEVER YOU
VISITED SAN LUIS OBISPO. I
DON'T THINK THERE IS A PERSON
IN SAN LUIS OBISPO THIS MORE
HOSPITABLE. THAN THAN CACHO WAS
TO HIS FRIENDS INVESTED
VISITORS HE WENT OUT OF HIS WAY
TO MAKE YOU FEEL WELCOME. OUT
OF HIS WAY TO TAKE YOU TO THE
BEST PLACES IN SAN LUIS OBISPO.
IN IN ONE OCCASION HE RENTED
ONE OF THOSE TROLLEY BUSES.
IT'S A TROLLEY THAT. DESIGNED
TO GO AROUND TOWN AND TAKE
PEOPLE IN GROUPS AND HE TOOK A
WHOLE GROUP OF US TOMORROW BAY
AND IT WAS JUST ONE OF THE MOST
MEMORABLE TRIPS. THE DRIVER
TOOK AND HE DID EVERYTHING TO
ENSURE THAT PEOPLE FELT WELCOME
AND THAT PEOPLE REALLY ENJOYED.
THE AT THE PLACE THREE LIVE
THAT HE WAS SO PROUD OF AND
THAT HE LOVES SO MUCH AND
ANYWHERE I WENT I MEAN IT'S
JUST AMAZING HOW MANY FRIENDS
HE HAD IN THIS IN THIS IS
NATIVE. IN THIS TOWN. AND THAT
NIGHT WERE WERE ON THE BUS HE
HE- I THINK YOU TOLD US THAT HE
WENT OVER ON THE TIME HIS
POSTER IN THE BUS AT SIX AND
ONE MUST HAVE BEEN LIKE SIX
THIRTY SO WE WERE DOING LIKE A
HUNDRED MILES AN HOUR ON
HIGHWAY. ONE NO ONE. ON THIS
THING AND EVERYBODY IS- ALL THE
WOMEN'SDRESSES WERE FLYING IN
THE WIND. BECAUSE I MEAN THIS
IS AN OPEN AIR BUS. AND THIS IS
THE BEST RIDE I'VE EVER HAD
BETTER THAN ANY DISNEY LINE THE
DIGITAL ACT THIS WITH I HAD SO
MUCH FUN THAT DAY. BUT IT WAS
IT WAS AMAZING I'LL NEVER
FORGET CAUGHT SHOW I LOST MY
DAD AROUND- THE SAME MADE TO
CACHO WAS AND- I GOT TO KNOW
HIS FAMILY OVER. DINNER
CONVERSATIONS BECAUSE WE PEOPLE
TALK POLITICS AND CURRENT
EVENTS CULTURE TALKED ABOUT HIS
CHILDREN ABOUT HIS WIFE. AND
THEY WERE YOU KNEW THAT THAT
WAS THE MOST IMPORTANT THING.
TO HIM THE WAY HE JUST TALKED
ABOUT HOW PROUD HE WAS OF HIS
SON. AND HIS DAUGHTER AND HOW
MUCH HE LOVED HIS WIFE AND I
JUST THOUGHT WHILE WITH. THIS
IS JUST A YOU KNOW A GREAT MAN
I HAD JUST SO MUCH RESPECT FOR
HIM. SO I KNOW MIGHT BE VERY
DIFFICULT FOR IT IS. HIS WIFE
AND CHILDREN. IT WAS VERY
DIFFICULT FOR ME TO LOSE MY DAD
AT AT YOU KNOW I. YOU KNOW I A
HIS SON WAS ABOUT MY AGE WHEN I
LOST MY DAD AND MY DAD WAS
CAUGHT SHOWS AGENT WAS A VERY
DIFFICULT THING TO HAVE TO- YOU
KNOW OF LIVE THROUGH AND I
STILL THINK ABOUT MY DAD EVERY
DAY AND HE STILL VISITS MEAN MY
DREAMS AND I KNOW. CULTURE WILL
BE LOOKING OUT FOR HIS FAMILY I
KNOW HE'LL BE LOOKING OUT FOR
SAN LUIS OBISPO I KNOW HE BE
LOOKING OUT FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA BUT WE WILL ALL MISS
SOME IN HIS LIFE WAS CUT SHORT.
WAY TOO SOON. AND I CAN'T THINK
OF A MEMBER THAT HAS SERVED IN
THE LEGISLATURE'S BEEN MORE
POPULAR ON BOTH SIDES OF THE
AISLE. THEN CUT CHURCH ASIAN
AND MAYBE THAT WILL BE HIS
LEGACY NOBODY WILL EVER BEAT
HIM IN THAT REGARD. AND I'M
JUST SO MANY STORIES TO SHARE
ABOUT HIM- THAT WOULD TAKE MUCH
TOO LONG BUT SIMPLY MEMBERS
THANK YOU FOR LETTING ME-
EULOGIZED MY FRIEND AND THANK
YOU FOR LET ME REMIND REMEMBER.
ALL THE WONDERFUL MEMORIES THAT
HE LEFT BEHIND AND ALL THE
WONDERFUL THINGS HE DID WHEN HE
SET UP FOR PEOPLE. HE DID IT
BECAUSE IT WAS THE RIGHT THING
TO DO AND I REMEMBER. SO MANY
STORIES OF HIM JUST SAYING. YOU
KNOW WHAT THE GOVERNMENT
GOVERNOR ASKED ME TO- FOR THIS
AND- I'M GOING TO DO WHAT'S
RIGHT. AND HE DID IT AND
BECAUSE OF THAT. HERE IN THE
RESPECT OF SO MANY PEOPLE.
THANK MEMBERS. THANK YOU SO
MUCH CENTER HUESO. MEMBERS
WOULD LIKE TO RECOGNIZE CENTER
MITCHELL. ADVENTURE THE FLOOR'S
YOURS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER PRESIDENT- I TO A MEMBER
OF THE CLASS OF TWENTY TEN OF
WHICH CULTURE WAS AND I AGREE
WITH EVERYTHING THAT WAS SAID
BY ALL OF OUR COLLEAGUE FROM
THE FLOOR I WOULD SIMPLY ADD
THAT HE AS AN ELEGANT.
THINKING MAN. AND I THINK
THAT'S WHAT ALL OF US
EXPERIENCED ON IN OUR
INTERPERSONAL RELATIONS WITH
HIM IN OUR RELATIONSHIPS WITH
HIM SERVING ON COMMITTEE AND
HEARING HIM STAND UP AND TAKE A
POSITION ON THE FLOOR- BECAUSE
HIS FAMILY WAS SO IMPORTANT TO
HIM. HE ALWAYS TOUCH BASES WITH
US IN OUR FAMILY AND- I HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TRAVEL WITH MY
FAMILY WITH CACCIA WHICH
ALLOWED HIM TO. DEVELOP A
RELATIONSHIP WITHOUT MY SON
THAT LASTED OVER THE YEARS AND-
CAUGHT CHILL MADE IT A HABIT OF
GIVING GIVING RYAN BOOKS. ON
THE NEXT TIME HE'D SEE HIM HE
WOULD ASK ME WHAT HE THOUGHT
ABOUT THAT BOOK. AND SO I WILL
FOREVER APPRECIATE CACHO FOR
EMBRACING MY FAMILY AS WELL-
THROUGHOUT YOUR CAREER HERE
WERE ALL CAPTURED IN IMAGES BY
THE PRESS. AND ONE OF THE MY
FAVORITE IMAGES THAT I WILL
ALWAYS HONOR AND APPRECIATE
WHICH WILL BRING A WARM SMILE
TO MY FACE. IS THE IMAGE
CAPTURE OF KHAT CHEWING ON THE
BACK OF THE CHAMBERS IN THE
ASSEMBLY BY. AP PHOTOGRAPHER
RICH PETROCELLI. AND WHAT MAKES
IT SO FUNNY IS **** AND I DON'T
HAVE A CLUE WHAT WE WERE SAYING
TO EACH OTHER. BECAUSE AFTER
THE PICTURE RAN IN THE LA TIMES
IT RUN IT REGULARLY WE WOULD
CUT IT OUT EVERY COUPLE RUN AND
SEND IT TO WORK TO EACH OTHER
AND LAUGH. AND KOCH WAS KISSING
ME ON MY CHEEK AND I'M HOLDING
A CUP OF HOT TEA. AND I'M
SAYING SOMETHING BACK TO ****
WHO IS HERE. AND WE HAVE NO
IDEA WHAT WE WERE SAYING TO
EACH OTHER. BUT WHATEVER IT WAS
YOU COULD TELL BY MY EXPRESSION
THAT- HOW WARM I FELT ABOUT
CACHO AND HOW MUCH FUN WE WERE
HAVING IN THAT MOMENT. AND SO I
APPRECIATE RICH FOR CAPTURING
JUST THAT MOMENT IN TIME
BETWEEN TWO COLLEAGUES THAT
REALLY IS A REFLECTION TO THE
WORLD. OF WHAT OUR
RELATIONSHIPS CAN BE WITH ONE
ANOTHER WHEN WE CHOOSE FOR THEM
TO BE I WANT TO JOIN WITH ALL
OF YOU. IN HONORING- ARE TWENTY
TEN CAT CLASSMATE. AT AN
ELEGANT THINKING MAN FORMER
ASSEMBLYMAN CACHO SHASHIN.
THANK YOU SO MUCH SENATOR UBER
IS RUNNING GIVE THE PROTEIN THE
LAST WORD PRO TWO MAC INSOFAR
AS YOURS WELL THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT AND- I DON'T DESERVE
THE LAST WORD BUT- I AM
THRILLED THAT I GOT TO HEAR
WHAT ALL OF MY COLLEAGUES HAVE
SAID ABOUT AN INCREASE
INCREDIBLE INDIVIDUAL. ALSO A
CLASS OF TWENTY TEN- WITH MY
COLLEAGUES HERE- HE WAS ONE OF
THE MOST- KIND INDIVIDUALS I
MEAN IT IS KIND OF AMAZING THAT
YOU SEE EVERYBODY IN BOTH
CHAMBERS OF GOAL IN EXTRA
ORDINARY DISTANCES TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE DO THIS RIGHT FOR
SOMEONE WHO TRULY DESERVED IT-
MY COMMENTS ARE NOT GOING TO BE
AS AS I THINK PROFOUND AS- THAT
OF MY COLLEAGUES BUT WE ALL
HAVE STORIES. YOU KNOW OP I
DON'T SMOKE CIGARS- BUT I HAVE
A HUMIDOR- THAT WAS GIVEN TO ME
BY CACHO- IT STORES GREAT
THINGS JUST NOT CIGARS- BUT IT
WAS JUST SUCH AN INCREDIBLE
GIFT BECAUSE WE HAD- TRAVEL TO
CUBA TOGETHER AND HE WAS IN
HEAVEN. IN CUBA- YOU CAN JUST
IMAGINE BUT- YOU KNOW TO SEE
THE RESPECTIVE EVERYONE HAS FOR
AN INDIVIDUAL OBVIOUSLY THERE
ARE LESSONS WE NEED TO LEARN IN
HUMANITY ABOUT HOW SOMEONE
COULD BE THAT KIND OF PERSON
ARE A DECENT HUMAN BEING
SOMEONE WHO ADORED HIS FAMILY
AS YOU'VE SAID. I AND SOMEONE
WHO RECOGNIZED YOUR FAMILY AND-
MY SPOUSE LOVED IT I MEAN WE
TRAVEL WHEN WE TRAVEL TO CUBA
TOGETHER TO IT LOOK IT AG AND
DO A NUMBER OF OTHER THINGS WE
CLEARLY HAD FUN HOWEVER IT WAS
AN ENJOYABLE TRIP. AND WHEN YOU
SAY- ONE OF MY COLLEAGUES SAID
HE WAS A MAN OF PRINCIPLE. WHEN
YOU'RE A AN OF PRINCIPLE AND
YOU KNOW WHO YOU ARE AND YOU
KNOW WHY YOU'RE IN A PLACE. HOW
IS IT POSSIBLE PEOPLE CAN BE
ANGRY AT YOU ARE OR- YOU KNOW
THIS IS AN INDIVIDUAL WHO WAS
ABLE TO- JUST DEFY. LABELS
FRANKLY. AND IT WAS JUST
GENUINELY A GOOD HUMAN BEING
AND I WILL SAY THANK YOU TO MY
COLLEAGUES. WHO REPRESENTED THE
SENATE. I IT'S NOT OFTEN I
THINK THAT SENATORS- AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS CROSS OVER
ALWAYS TO RECOGNIZE UNLESS
THEY'VE SERVED WITH SOMEONE.
BUT MANY OF YOU MIGHT NOT HAVE
SERVED WITH CACHO ACTUALLY BUT
YOU KNEW HIM AND YOU KNEW WHO
HE WAS AND YOU KNEW THE
RESPECT. THAT HE HELD- THE
REPUBLICAN LEADER SAID HE WAS A
STATESMAN I COULDN'T AGREE
MORE. AND WE HAVE LOST AN
INCREDIBLE STATESMAN AND I WANT
TO THANK MY COLLEAGUES FOR
TAKING THE TIME TO GO REPRESENT
US. OZ SO THAT HIS FAMILY KNEW
THAT IT WAS WIDE WIDELY HELD.
THAT HE WAS SOMEONE THAT MADE A
DIFFERENCE IN OUR STATE AND FOR
THIS INSTITUTION. THANK YOU FOR
LETTING ME ADD A FEW WERE. IN
HONOR OF A GREAT MAN AND PAY
RESPECTS TO HIS INCREDIBLE
FAMILY. A BETTER BRITAIN THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR. THOSE ELEGANT
WORDS MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR
HONORING THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER IN
A TRUE THE GRACEFUL WAY. WE'RE
GONNA TAKE A FEW MOMENTS THERE
IS SOME PAPERWORK HERE AT THE
DESK THAT WE'RE GONNA NEED TO
BE ABLE TO ORGANIZE AND WE'RE
GONNA ASK ALL SENATORS TO BE A
REMAIN ON THE FLOOR. ALL
SENATORS ARE NEED TO REMAIN ON
THE FLOOR. DO APPRECIATE YOUR
PATIENCE WE BACK WITH YOU HERE
IN A FEW MOMENTS.
WE'RE GONNA
ASK THAT ALL SENATORS REPORT TO
THE FLOOR ALL SENATORS REPORT
TO THE FLOOR.
SENATOR FOR WHAT
PURPOSE. FOR MISTER PRESIDENT I
WOULD TO A- THAT TODAY IS
SENATOR SCOTT WILKES BIRTHDAY.
AND SO WE SHOULD ALWAYS HIM A
HAPPY BIRTHDAY FOR SPENDING IT
WITH US TONIGHT ON THIS
AUSPICIOUS OCCASION ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE
WE WISH YOU HAPPY BIRTHDAY.
WHEN WAITERS NOT ALLOWED TO USE
ANOTHER CENTERS NAME ON THE
FLOOR. DURING DEBATE ONLY OR
DEBATE I'M OVER I DID NOT SAY
SCOTT WELL THAT WAS NOT ME BUT
IT SCOTT WILKES BIRTHDAY. THANK
HAPPY BIRTHDAY SENATOR.
MEMBERS
RETURN YOUR MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS. CENTER PRO TEM.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT I
WOULD REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT
TO TAKE UP ACR ONE EIGHTY NINE
WITHOUT REFERENCE TO FILE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION. MR KERRY
PLEASE RATE. ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION ONE
EIGHTY NINE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
RENDON. RELATIVE TO THE TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY REGULAR SESSION
OF THE LEGISLATURE. OUR PRO TEM
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT I
WOULD- COLLEAGUES ASK AS I
SHARED WITH YOU TODAY WE'VE
HEARD FROM HEALTH PROFESSIONALS
THAT CALIFORNIA ISIN A
CRITICAL PERIOD FOR FLATTENING
THE TRANSMISSION KERR FOR
COVERT NINETEEN IF FOR TO
PREVENT OUR HEALTH CARE SYSTEMS
ARE BEING OVERWHELMED. WITH
THAT IN MIND I PRESENT THIS
RESOLUTION TO RECESS THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE UNTIL
APRIL THIRTEENTH TWENTY TWENTY
EXCEPT AS FOLLOWS AND MY
COLLEAGUE SHOULD HAVE THE PRINT
OUT OF THE LANGUAGE- THAT GIVES
THE- EXCEPT AS FOLLOWS AND IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT YOU TAKE A LOOK
AT THAT HEY. EITHER HOUSE MAY
RECALL ITSELF FROM THE JOINT
RECESS THE LEGISLATURE MAY
RECESS BY JOINT PROCLAMATION OF
THE PRESIDENT PRO TEMPORE A OF
THE SENATE AND THE SPEAKER OF
THE ASSEMBLY THE LEGISLATURE
MAY EXTEND THE JOINT RECESS BY
JOINT PROCLAMATION OF THE
PRESIDENT PRO TEMPORE OF THE
SENATE AND THE SPEAKER OF THE
ASSEMBLY. DE IF THE GOVERNOR OR
GOVERNOR'S DESIGNATE DECLARES
THAT CONTINUED HOME ISOLATION
IS OR SIMILAR PREVENTIVE
MEASURES ARE NECESSARY TO
ADDRESS THE CURRENT STATE OF
EMERGENCY THE JOINT RECESS
SHALL BE EXTENDED UNTIL THE
LEGISLATURE RECALLS ITSELF FROM
THE JOINT RECESS. THAT IS THE
EXTENT AND I WANT TO BE VERY
CLEAR THAT EVEN THOUGH WE MAY
NOT SEE IS LIKELY BE IN THE
CAPITALWE WILL CONTINUE
WORKING IN OUR DISTRICTS TO
SERVE OUR CONSTITUENTS WE'RE
COMMITTED TO PROTECTING THE
HEALTH OF ALL CALIFORNIANS- AND
I WOULD ENCOURAGE ALL
CALIFORNIANS TO PLEASE FALL THE
ADVICE OF OUR PUBLIC HEALTH
OFFICIALS. OUT WITH THAT I
WOULD ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. WE
NEED. OF THE- IN GROW I TO
RAISE AN SUPPORT OF THIS RARE
YOU KNOW IT'S THAT WE SHOW AND
WHAT'S GOING ON ACROSS THE
WORLD AND ESPECIALLY IN THE
UNITED STATES IN CALIFORNIA AND
LEADERSHIP IS IT HEARING TO THE
RULES THAT HELP PREVENTS THE
SPREADING OF COVERT NINETEEN IN
MAKING SURE THAT WE- LEAD BY
EXAMPLE SO I APPLIED THE SENATE
PRO TEM FOR WORKING UP THE
LANGUAGE WITH SPEAKER. AND I
KNOW THAT TIME TO THINK THAT
JUST BECAUSE WE'RE NOT HERE IN
SACRAMENTO THAT WE ARE NOT
GOING TO WORK I A I KNOW THAT
ALL OF US KNOW THAT IS
ABSOLUTELY POSITIVELY NOT TRUE
WE WILL BE RESPONSIBLE IN OUR
DISTRICTS TO RESPOND TO THE
LOCAL ISSUES THAT ARE TAKING
PLACE WE WILL GO HOME AND FACE
THE FACT THAT ALMOST EVERYONE
OF OUR SCHOOLS HAVE CLOSED.
PEOPLE ARE BEING REQUESTED NOT
TO MEET- WITH OVER TEN PEOPLE
IN PRESENCE WHICH WILL AFFECT
OUR AFFECT OUR CHURCHES AND
THEM A LOT OF BUSINESSES AND SO
OUR WORK IT WILL BECOME HARDER
THAN ALL OF US BEING RIGHT HERE
IN THIS BUILDING TRYING TO
ADDRESS LEGISLATIVE ISSUES THAT
COME UP SO I THINK WITH THIS
AND WE'RE WELL. IN OUR
DISTRICTS TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR
DISTRICTS ARE TAKEN CARE OF
THIS IS NOT WHAT YOU WOULD
THINK IS GOING TO BE A FREE
VACATION AND I KNOW NONE OF YOU
THINK THAT I KNOW THAT E ARE
I'M HEADED HOME TO HARDER WORK
THAN WE'VE EVER FACED BEFORE IN
THIS BUILDING AND SO I
CHALLENGE YOU TO BE TO MEET THE
NEEDS OF YOUR DISTRICT WHICH I
KNOW YOU WILL. AND LET US
CONTINUE TO WORK TOGETHER TO
SOLVE CALIFORNIA'S PROBLEMS I'M
IN EVERY PART OF THE STATE AND
NOT JUST YOU KNOW IN EVERY PART
OF THE STATE BECAUSE I KNOW
WE'RE ALL FACING THIS TOGETHER.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION A- SCENE
HERE NUNS. MADAM PRO TO. WHICH
CLOSE. I YES I WILL DO THE VERY.
FIVE AND WILL HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENTS AS WE CLOSE. FOR THE
EVENING- I WANT TO THANK ALL OF
YOU FOR- THESE CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT STEPS THAT WE'VE
TAKEN TODAY AND AYE I EACH AND
EVERYONE OF YOU I WANT TO THANK
BUT I WANT TO EXPAND MY
INCREDIBLE THANKS TO THE
REPUBLICAN LEADER. WE I THINK
HAVE PUT PARTISAN POLITICS
ASIDE TO COME TOGETHER TO TAKE
THESE ACTIONS TODAY. AND FIVE
WE AS YOU CAN SEE WE HAVE BEEN
LOOKING AT EVERY POSSIBLE
ACTION TO TAKE IN ORDER FOR THE
STATE SENATE TO DO OUR PART IN
THIS CRISIS. I DESCRIBE SEVERAL
SEVERAL OF THOSE ACTIONS
EARLIER TODAY OUR
CONSIDERATIONS HAVE BEEN
SCIENCE DRIVEN AND BASED IN
BOTH PROTECTING THE PUBLIC
HEALTH AND MAINTAINING ACCESS
TO THIS PUBLIC INSTITUTION.
RESPONDING TO THE CORRUPT
CORONAVIRUS IS ONE OF THE
BIGGEST CHALLENGES TO FACE THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE IN
MODERN TIMES. THE RESPONSIBLE
THING FR US TO DO IS TO HELP
FLATTEN THE CURB REDUCE
TRANSMISSION KEEP OUR HEALTH
CARE SYSTEM ABOVE WATER. THAT
IS THE INTENT OF THE ACTIONS
THAT WE ARE TAKING THAT DOES
NOT MEAN. AS THE REPUBLICAN
LEADER SAID THE SENATE WILL BE
CLOSED IN ANY SENSE OF THE WORD
IN FACT I THINK VERY LIKELY
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE MORE WORK
THAN EVER TO DO. IN ADDITION TO
PROVIDING OUR CONSTITUENTS WAS
SUPPORT INFORMATIONAND
GUIDANCE. TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
HEALTH ON COVERT NINETEEN THERE
ARE STILL A CRISIS AND HOUSING
HOMELESSNESS POTENTIAL
DEVASTATION FROM WILDFIRES ANC
LEVEL RISE. STILL PROGRESS IT
NEEDS TO BE MADE ON A HOST OF
CHALLENGES FACING OUR STATE. WE
WILL BE PREPARED ON A MOMENT'S
NOTICE TO RETURN TO ADDRESS ANY
URGENT ACTION THAT WE MUST AND
NEED TO TAKE. I MENTIONED
EARLIER SOME OF THE STAFF WHOSE
WORK IN THE BUILDING ARE
CRITICAL TO ENSURING THE
MECHANICS OF THE LEGISLATURE
AND THE CAPITAL KEEP GOING. I
KNOW MANY OF MY STAFF WILL
CONTINUE WORKING IN THE
BUILDING AS WELL WHILE OTHERS-ARE MY STAFF WILL WORK REMOTELY
YOURS AS WELL. BUT I HAVING A
MIX OF FOLKS WORKING IN THE
BUILDING AND WORKING REMOTELY
WE ABSOLUTELY DO LESSEN THE
RISK. AND AGAIN WE DO OUR PART
TO HELP FLATTEN OCCUR. SO
COLLEAGUES YOU KNOW I KNOW IT'S
GOING TO TAKE PATIENTS AND
SACRIFICE FROM ALL OF US IN
THIS STATE TO MITIGATE THIS
PANDEMIC. AND MINIMIZE ITS HARM
TO OUR HEALTH CARESYSTEMS AND
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA. WE
WILL KEEP YOU UPDATED WITH THE
VERY BEST INFORMATION WE CAN IN
THE DAYS AND WEEKS AHEAD. SO
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT FOR
THE ADDITIONAL TIME. PLEASE I
URGE AN AYE VOTE. MEMBERS IS
THERE ANY OBJECTION TO USING A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON THE SIDE
OF. SEE NINE OZ THIRTY TWO NO
ZERO. THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
WHAT IS THAT I'M SORRY SENATOR
YEAH AND I IT'S IT REGARDING
THAT ALSO BE UNDER A WE CAN GO
TO MOTIONS RESOLUTIONS IF THAT
WOULD BE A APPROPRIATE. WORD
NOW IT MORE WERE. SOONER BREAUX
THANK YOU MISTER. I DIDN'T
REALIZE THAT WE WERE TALKING
ABOUT RECESS I THOUGHT WE WERE
TALKING ABOUT THE SPECIFIC BILL
OF. REGARDING RECESS BUT I KNEW
THAT THE SENATE PRO TEM AND I
WERE GOING TO MAKE CLOSING
REMARKS AND- SO I APOLOGIZE
SENATE PRETEND FOR NOT MAKING
MY CLOSING REMARKS AT THE
PREPARATORY. BUT I DID WANT TO
SHARE WITH YOU THAT. ONE OF MY
FAVORITE SCRIPTURES AS ROMANS
EIGHT TWENTY EIGHT. AM IT'S HAS
GOTTEN WORK ALL THINGS OUT
TOGETHER FOR GOOD FOR THOSE OF
US WHO LIVE IN THE CALLED
ACCORDING TO HIS PURPOSE. AND I
THINKABOUT OUR SESSION I'VE
BEEN HERE SIX YEARS IN THE
ASSEMBLY AND NOW YEAR AND A
HALF IN THE SENATE. AND I'VE
NEVER FACED A LEGISLATIVE
SESSION LIKE WE FACE HERE
TODAY. AND NOT TO MENTION WHAT
WE FACE THE LAST NIGHT OF
SESSION. LAST YEAR WHEN WE WERE
HERE SO THERE HAVE BEEN
SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGES WHERE
WE- EVEN THOUGH OPPOSITE SIDE
THE AISLE WE'VE COME TOGETHER.
AND OVERCAME A LOT OF THINGS.
THE LAST NIGHT A SESSION FOR
INSTANCE. WE OVERCAME LEAVING
THIS PART OF THE CHAMBER AND
GOING INTO A- REMOTE LOCATION
AND THE STAFF PULLED TOGETHER
AND MADE SURE THAT EVERY VOTE
COUNTED IN THAT WE HAD. THE
PROTECTIONS. A CONSTITUTIONALLY
AND- TO PROVE TO THE PUBLIC
THAT WE ACTUALLY CAST THOSE
VOTES HAD MADE THOSE DECISIONS.
SO WHEN I THINK ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENED THIS TIME WITH CODE
NINETEEN AND I THINK ABOUT WHAT
THE SENATE PRO TEM AND I HAVE.
GONE THROUGH. I AM NOT JUST S.
BUT I JUST REALLY DO. I WANT TO
SAY THAT I WOULD NOT RATHER AND
NO OFFENSE TO ANYBODY IN THE
ROOM BUT I WOULD RATHER. AND
SHOULDER TO SHOW. WITH SENATE
PRO TEM TONI ATKINS. ON THIS
ISSUE FACING OUR STATE. BECAUSE
SHE PROVIDES FAIR LEADERSHIP.
SHE INCLUDES S. AND I THINK
THAT WHEN I WHEN I QUOTED THAT
SCRIPTURE EARLIER I THINK
ABOUT. THE PRESIDENT THE UNITED
STATES WORKING WITH THE
GOVERNOR OF THE STATE OF%
CALIFORNIA. THE GOVERNOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA SPEAKING POSITIVELY
ABOUT THE RELATIONSHIP GOING ON
WITH THE PRESENT UNITED STATES
IN THE ADMINISTRATION TO SOLVE
pTEM THE DEMOCRAT LEADER OF THE
HOUSE AND THE SENATE MINORITY
LEADER THE REPUBLICAN LEADER OF
THE HOUSE WORKING TOGETHER WITH
OUR CAUCUSES TO SOLVE THIS
PROBLEM. AND SO I THINK THAT
THAT JUST SHOWS THAT. YOU KNOW
WE CAN WORK TOGETHER ON ISSUES
THAT FACE CALIFORNIANS AND MAKE
SURE THAT ALL CALIFORNIANS ARE
PROTECTED AND SAFE AND THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING IS THE
PROTECTION AND HEALTH AND
SAFETY OF ALL CALIFORNIANS. NO
WE HAVE A LOT OF WORK TO CUT
OUT FOR US. AND I THINK THAT.
WE OWE A GREAT DEAL OF
GRATITUDE TO ERICA CONTRARIES
WHO'S THE PRESIDENT OF THE
SENATE. HE HAS PUT TOGETHER A
PLAN TO MAKE SURE THAT
CONSTITUTIONALLY WE ARE- ABLE
TO CAST A VOTE IF WE CANNOT
COME BACK IN CAST A VOTEHERE.
SHE IS PUT TOGETHER A PLAN TO
MAKE SURE THAT ALL OF OUR STAFF
HERE YOU KNOW THREE THOUSAND OR
SO EMPLOYEES IN THIS BUILDING.
THAT WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT.
MATT THERE'S ME WE HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY AS EMPLOYERS NOT
JUST LEGISLATORS TO GOVERN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA BE A PART
OF THAT PROCESS. BERNIE AND
EVERYBODY THAT'S PARTICIPATED
IN THIS PROJECT THE SERGEANTS
THE CHIEF YOU KNOW EVERYBODY
THAT'S PARTICIPATED IN MAKING
SURE THAT WE'VE BEEN SAFE IN
THIS BUILDING. THE G. S. I MEAN
THE LIST GOES ON AND ON BUT
NUMBER ONE I THINK IT JUST
SHOWS. GREAT STATESMANSHIP FOR
EVERYONE OF YOU TO WORK WITH
THE S. YOU COULD'VE RAMROD
ANYTHING YOU WANTED THROUGH
THIS BUILDING WITHOUT ANY
CONSIDERATION OF OUR THOUGHT
PROCESS WHATSOEVER. AND I JUST
SUPPLY THE SENATE PRO TEM IN
THE GOVERNOR FOR MAKING SURE
THAT WE WERE INCLUDED IN THE
PROCESS- THERE WERE SOME
MISHAPS AND WE VOICE OUR
OPINION ABOUT THOSE MISHAPS.
THE IMMEDIATELY CORRECTED THEM
AND MAKE SURE THAT WE WERE A
PART OF THE PROCESS. BECAUSE
THIS ISN'T A PARTISAN ISSUE
THIS IS SOMETHING ABOUT
PROTECTING THE CITIZENS OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. SO I WANT
TO THANK ALL OF YOU ON BEHALF
OF MY SENATE COLLEAGUES- ON THE
SIDE OF THE AISLE AND TELL YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR ALL
THAT YOU'VE DONE TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE WERE A PART OF THIS
PROCESS. TO HELP THE CITIZENS
OF CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND SAFETY
ISSUE. MEMBERS WERE RETURNING
TO MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS.
WITHOUT OBJECTION MEASURES
REPORTED DURING RECESS WITH
AUTHORS AMENDMENTS WILL BE
ADOPTED AND PUBLISHED. META PRO
TEM THE DEFICITS COLOR. MISTER
PRESIDENT THANK YOU I THINK
THAT WAS AN ELOQUENT CLOSE ON
THE PART OF MY- CALLING THE
REPUBLICAN LEADER AND WITH OUR
THANKS- WE BID YOU SAFE TRAVELS
HOME- AND WE WILL KEEP YOU
INFORMED. MISTER PRESIDENT. WE
ARE GOING TO RECESS. MEMBERS
THE SENATE WILL BE IN RECESS
UNTIL THREE THIRTY IN THE NEXT.
THE SENATE IS IN RECESS GERMAN
MOTION WILL BE MADE. WHERE
RECESS. I WAS GONNA SAY I
THOUGHT THE.